[Music]
we're inside the playing Hall here the
second and final day of our title match
the 2023 Champions chess tour will
finally come to an end after eight
amazing days in Toronto and boy was it
amazing we had youthful Rising Stars
show up ready to battle but ultimately
even the superstars were sent home by
two men they were the best through the
early stages and they Remain the best
here in Rapid chess they are Wesley so
and Magnus Carlson does Wesley so do
what he's already done win a tiebreaker
and forc dramatic Armageddon or does the
goat Magnus Carlson win in a clean sweep
it all comes down to today this is the
final moments of the 2023 Champions
chess tour and it begins right
now you've heard the sayings The Road
Less Traveled rubber meets the road I'm
on the road to nowhere that need to get
up and go to just shut up and drive the
parts Unknown it's in our DNA but this
road has an end and the
beginning well let's throw that in
Reverse it's over we have a winner
Magnus Carlson what has this kid got in
store he
might one move Checkmate there's been
curves Hills corners and even a
breakdown or two the game is over that's
the we see a reaction Magnus Magnus
Mouse SLI oh my gosh look at Jan's face
some have pulled over but some oh what
is he doing slam that foot to the floor
and just kept going any
seconda is the winner
not Maxim vaj the Frenchman he wins the
AI cup after six stops along the way
it's time for the greatest proven ground
and online chess to drop that final pin
in the
GPS destination Toronto Canada eight
players from all four corners of the
globe descend on the Queen City with one
goal to prove who the one true king of
online chess really is I think this is
the strongest final there's ever been I
know that it will not be easy it's nice
to play in top tournament Magnus will
want revenge it's my last tournament of
the year I'm a bit desperate to end it
well having the opportunity to play
against the best players in the world
it's always a challenge and I enjoy it
it's going to be a very close fight it's
going to be very exciting live from
Toronto Canada this is the 2023
Champions chess tour final
and it starts
[Music]
now we are live from Toronto Canada
taking a look maybe the final look at
the very very beautiful Queen City the
CN tower looks overall what a shot there
I don't know if it was sunrise eyes or
sunet but I'm into it and we are here in
the playing Hall it is the final day no
matter what happens it all comes down to
this Danny wrench KY Levy Rosman this is
it guys Levy you brought your best suit
I did I guess we're going we're going
out after this we're going out after
this we got the UFC event after this I
just had to channel my inner Bruce
Buffer I Stark I don't want to do it so
I don't but true I'm so excited one
thing you can't say but K didn't say it
you ready for this ready for this man
it's the last day guys we got to get
some Champions uh or Champions going to
be Crown today it's a lot of money on
the line Danny this coming out of your
pocket or is that a that's
200,000 that's a lot this is the
culmination of the whole calendar year
of events this is it I love that you
said that cuz it really is this is more
than just what we've been through here
over eight days this is the culmination
of so many amazing events so much hard
work by so many players it all comes
down to these two guys we know we have a
lot to break down when it comes to their
chess yeah present I'm ready for it you
know like I'm ready for y ready at home
all right let's remind everybody of how
we got here it was an amazing semifinals
yesterday the bracket will remind you of
uh as I said the semi-finals between so
and Abdus tur up in Carlson Carana but
that wasn't yesterday yesterday was the
first day of the title match Magnus
Carlson got it done in regulation we
didn't even need Armageddon but if you
look in that upper left corner a
reminder Wesley so has been here before
it was the exact same score hey it's
Rhyme Time and he refused to walk out
that door I'm continuing to see whether
we can keep this going because Wesley so
is going to have to keep it going here
if we're going to if we're still going
to be here for a very very long day so
all right let's remind you of what we
saw on day seven you see the scoreboard
but what were the highlights take it
away day one of the CCT title match gave
us a wild start with the extremely rare
1 B3 and nearly perfect chess despite
the offbeat first move Wesley maintained
an equal game throughout ending in a
draw both players were incredibly
precise with nearly 99% accuracy each
the second game they outdid themselves
this time playing over 99% accuracy also
ending in a draw game three was a wild
back and forth that seemed to Trend
towards a drawn Rook endgame somehow
Magnus managed to conjure his famous
endgame magic and a mistake from Wesley
with 4 seconds on the clock allowed
Magnus to push his F Pawn to decide the
game White's Rook is keeping that black
B Pawn under lock and key and why is he
allowed the black pawn to run his King
could have stepped across the final game
of the set was a must-win for Wesley and
he had the black pieces despite Wesley's
best efforts to create a dynamic
position with attacking chances Magnus
was simply too solid never conceding any
significant Edge Wesley's extra Pawn was
not enough as the game simplified down
to a draw with Bishops and pawns on the
board can Wesley come back from a one-
set deficit against Magnus
it was dramatic it was dramatic you see
a slightly dejected there an
apprehensive Wesley so according to
Magnus Carlson mhm no that's exactly
what happened um I it really felt like
Wesley just sort of he he wanted a very
slow start to the match Magnus created a
little bit of imbalance in that third
game you called it Sicilian and and it
was just like it was just a tiny bit in
One Direction one guy had a slight
chance and and that was the entire match
yeah summary of yesterday's match up so
that was the difference in the match it
wasn't very different between these two
guys you see less than a couple accuracy
points over 98% Shenanigans but that's
what it takes to beat a guy who's
playing 96% plus and you saw what Wesley
we saw what Wesley did there in terms of
accuracy but we also saw what Magnus
said about what it takes to beat the guy
he said sometimes I got to hustle my way
to a victory what does that actually
mean on the chess board yeah not even
sometimes I think he said that's how
I've beaten West over the course of my
career I hustle him the lower ELO
hustling is like look the fans at home
no you're down a queen it's not over
never resign you could beat somebody on
time you could bribe somebody you know
maybe someone's internet disconnects you
beat somebody down to Queens let me show
you what hustling means at the elite
Grandmaster level this is from game
three The Rook end game yesterday
between Magnus and Wesley Magnus with
the black pieces four pawns versus three
we just do the math you think black is
better well at this moment Wesley
started walking with his King to the
right side and he was going after
magnus's H Pawn while his pawns were
falling Magnus grabbed the pawn on B4
and then Wesley lined up The Rook on B7
to both cut off Black's King and Target
The Pawn on B5 and F7 despite being two
pawns down this is still a draw you put
Magnus here with the white pieces he's
probably going to save the day right
like he's probably just going to make a
draw but Wesley took the pawn on H5 and
then a couple of moves later we can roll
the footage until the move F5 and Wesley
had to go back with his King to G here
that was what he had to do it was one
tiny decision with less than 10 seconds
on the clock but instead of that he got
into a race and he is not going to stop
both of magnus's Pawns just keep it
rolling you notice magnus's pawns
rolling the B and F pawns all the way
down the board and ultimately that is
what was decisive let's keep going you
see Wesley pushes his Pawn F2 Rook B8
and Wesley had to resign because his
pawns are just not as fast his Pawn I
should say his one pawn magnus's two
pawns are much faster and that's what
Magnus calls hustling but it's what we
call Magic all right because he just
takes that tiny microscopic moment in a
game and he takes advantage of his
opponent's misstep and that's that's why
that match yesterday was was that close
and that's how Magnus got it done we
like to call that Magnus doing Magnus
things let's see what it looks like on
paper KY break it down for us Magnus
doing Magnus things when we talk about
what he's done here in Toronto yeah I
mean look at this well first off this
stat is looking the same as I've
mentioned before as Wesley's 5- one
overall I mean lost to Wesley and then
vice versa I mean Magnus or Wesley lost
to Magnus Magnus lost to Wesley like
eight brilliancies right second most
tied with Wesley so right and 93.9 uh
five highest in the CCT finals for the
accuracy the man is is a machine half
man half something else but there's one
loss there in Armageddon that is that
five and one record was for a reason so
for fans tuning in and doing the
obligatory thing I got to see Magnus win
another title not so fast right one man
has stopped him so far can Wesley so do
it again well don't disrespect him it's
Flex so Flex Sano thank you very much
now at the same time of course Flex so
solid is what we we call him these days
but beforehand he actually was a very
aggressive player in fact as we see in
this game that he played with Magnus
here that Infamous game where he sacked
a piece guys w we started right here he
said I'm going night G5 and we live he
hit that boy with a nasty one very mean
this is the very this is the Wesley we
remember before he became Wesley so
solid now Knight G5 after a takes G5
there's Bishop takes G5 right so he
sacked a piece here Magnus just like w
he just sacked a piece on me my guy let
me chill let me relax right then okay
let's fast forward here after Knight E5
happens we uh follow up Queen F2 there
we go got the moves Knight D7 and then
E5 this is another one like he sacked a
piece then he sacks a pawn who is this
you would never think this is Wesley so
at all and then after Pawn takes Pawn
the Knight comes in to E4 after Knight
E4 Queen B6 and then Queen H4 check
right from Wesley allowing KN H5 cuz
we're going to take on F6 first so
Knight H5 happened for Magnus after
Knight H5 we need to get our pieace back
hence to move G4 from Wesley here G4 pin
the night right now we were able to get
a peace sacrifice and we get our peace
back and put black under some pressure
here where let's fast forward as we see
that Magnus had to sacrifice his queen
in fact and it was actually forced there
was one line that he could have chosen
but it was hard to see that after night
takes Rook takes you know Bishop takes
was better but he had to sacrifice his
Queen which allowed Wesley to go on and
win this game right here so Flex so if
he has a game like this or something
maybe attack Magnus like you said before
we may have some different chances a
game like this a game like that that's
what a lot of people are hoping for I
think even Magnus Carlson fans are
secretly hoping for that Wesley so to
show up today right and he's going to
have to if he wants the larger piece of
what's at stake we don't talk about it a
lot but this is also a one of the
richest tournaments that any of these
guys will play in this is a half a
million dollars on the line we got a lot
of Mone that's the flex
a lot giving out a lot of money that's
what we're doing it's $200,000 for first
place obviously second is a six figure
sum as well not a bad payday but the
truth is that's double your money double
the fun can Wesley show up I could use
some double mint gum after this I've had
a lot of coffee I'm just saying that
they are not a sponsor of this show but
all right it's time for us to check in
with someone who is a part of this show
her name is Kaa and she's waiting just
outside hey Danny yep I'm out here in
the lounge pouring myself some energy
before for a big day also looking for
the players they should arrive very
shortly hoping to get a question in with
both Magnus and Wesley before it all
kicks off and I've actually been doing
some detective work over the last 20
hours been trying to figure out what the
players are doing before the final day
of the CCT finals and well I almost feel
like I should have a tobacco pipe and
and magnifying glass because I've been
looking for them everywhere and here's
what I found out so Magna spent an hour
at the fan Zone yesterday having some
pizza hanging now with people he came
back to the hotel I saw him going into
the elevator and since he's not been
spotted not at the restaurant for for
breakfast not for dinner he's not been
spotted in the lobby he's not been at
the gym and the same is for Wesley so
and I think that means the two players
have been in their rooms in their hotel
rooms they've been having um room
service and probably just preparing for
this very final day the action that will
take place here today so it's going to
be exciting I'm looking forward to this
day a lot we'll have some coffee but in
a few hours Danny we'll switch this up
with some
champagne we will have champagne as
you're saying Ka at the end of the day
because no matter what happens whether
it's a long one or a short one we are
going to have a winner we are going to
Crown our 2023 Champions chess tour
champion and all right but before we do
that guys I know that people are
wondering how long will this day be
let's remind them that Wesley so was the
man to beat a few years ago in Oslo that
was the kind of Wesley so that a lot of
people uh would like to see the kind of
Wesley so that we know is capable of
this he won the world Fisher random
Championship shout out to soo and Yas
look at that I looked a little younger
in that man I have aged over the
stressful the stressful chess boom Oh my
God we got to talk about that but there
you go here were the players with the
flowers Wesley was all smiles Magnus
Carlson was not all smiles and he didn't
hide it he wanted to win this event make
no mistake and you know I caught up with
Magnus a little bit yesterday walking
home from the the fans I want to go back
to the comments you guys have both made
about Wesley already which is Magnus
said I hustle him because he doesn't
really take his chances but when he does
you see what he's capable of in
Armageddon and Magnus was actually
talking about the fourth game they had
where Wesley almost won with black it
wasn't a huge adantage but at some point
Wesley was doing the things that you
expect him to do and Magnus said he's
like I just you know he doesn't play
chess like that that often he's got to
do it today oh yeah he he has absolutely
no choice this is basically uh actually
a gentleman who's fighting later today
Leon Edwards in his second fight against
kamaro Usman it was round five and he's
lost the first four rounds I mean maybe
he won round one and then he was down
three to one like Wesley doesn't have a
choice he's got to throw a head kick and
he's got to go for The Knockout he has
to win the second set and then he's got
to force a tiebreak he he can't play
that graphic that we showed was great
98% versus 96.4 and honestly the
brilliancy Wesley was credited with was
like one of those you know it was like a
they made no brilliancies and no
blunders as far as I'm concerned it was
a really really really closed day Les
Ley can't have that again because if
they have that type of day Magnus is
probably going to win we need to see a
Checkmate on the board today or it's
going to it's going to be an early night
that's actually correct in fact one
thing Magnus said I remember this from a
YouTube video or something that Magnus
said he was like yeah a lot of players
actually are as skilled as I am it's
just the confidence the mental part as
we saw yesterday in fact even in some of
the games that we saw from Wesley you
could just tell the confidence wasn't
there it wasn't the Wesley that we saw
before you can see him dejected you can
see some nerves through how his body
language was telling us so having a
little bit more confidence if is's able
to bring that today maybe we'll have a
different Wesley you could see the
nerves the fans want to see more than
that from Wesley and speaking of the
fans the fan zone is uh is bumping I
think the kids say things like
that sound cool but all right we're
going to be checking in with it
throughout the day but we caught up with
many of them yesterday asked them how
they were enjoying it who they had in
the match and other questions enjoy this
take from our live fan
[Music]
Zone I this is just the place to be in
Toronto today like walking in here you
walk past Grand Masters you walk past
the chest F standing together with them
it is so cool to be here between Magnus
and Wesley so who do you think is going
to win okay I'll probably play safe I'll
say Magnus but I don't think it'll be
easy for him oh I don't know Magnus
maybe Magnus Magnus yeah like Magnus but
in Armageddon something pretty close
Magnus but I Love Wesley too yeah good
answer I'm going to go with Wesley so I
I think Wesley gets like a A plus 100
Toronto buff to his ELO and I think
that's going to be enough to overtake
Magnus team Wesley so all day
long anything can happen in chess you
know like we'll see who can beat the
goat here yeah I think W is very cold
blood is let's see what happen first of
all Dennis curious how's your experience
being in Canada very I'm very happy to
be here is it your first time in North
America us or Canada yeah yes this
my all right we can't end the day
without giving a shout out to the chess
bras here for their thing of course
Magnus came in he's still here the fans
are nuts this is literally like a dream
come true for chess and uh the part's
just beginning we're going to go have a
good time next time there's a chance to
join us at a fan Zone hope you take us
up on it
peace
there are a bunch of fans who took us up
on it in fact I hear the line was long
out the door because people were showing
up maybe just to test that theory that
it was sold out people were showing up
who didn't have tickets and I've been
told a lot of them had to be sent away
because that thing actually did sell out
and I physically visited yesterday let
me just say it was uncomfortable
physically given how many human beings
were stacked up against other human
beings so I say that not in like a bad
way I'm saying it really roundabout
compliment but yeah it was it was was a
legit leg you all made Danny
uncomfortable
made fan Zone that's right that's right
but all right no it was it's a ton of
fun and we'll probably back there today
we see Aman and Eric already camming it
up having fun with the fans that is a
live shot right now and um speaking of
fun we know they're going to have fun at
some point here we're going to get down
to the serious business but you guys
threw down right here and had some fun
we did I was I was there hiding in the
dark watching it and let me just say got
spicy between these two
guys this crazy oh my God I don't feel
it yet because there's so much spice
already in my mouth TR thermost up
please milk no milk milk James I'm going
to go to the
ambulance what's up everyone chess as
hard as it is but we're about to make it
even harder by playing chili chess for
every type of piece we capture we are
going to eat a chip with some hot sauce
on it starting with the PM Knights
Bishops and Rooks a queen and then the
loser of the game is going to eat this
wrenched chip over here while I'm here
with soon to be International master and
then grandmas James KY I third how you
doing man I'm feeling good man play oh
sorry sorry my bad oh yeah yeah I got a
high spice tolerance so I think you're
probably pretty good with yours
too not at all no I'm ready though I'm
ready man what's the time for what we
playing 3 minutes every time we hit the
clock we get an extra 2 seconds ready to
go
yeah we go and here we
go oh man we battled a lot in the it's
like you letting me take it bro we we
get it's you must be hungry bro I'm too
scared to capture take it bro no no no
no cuz then we have to eat the you know
what now you got to eat the freaking
chip all so
big yes all right oh
man it feels like I'm inhaling a
barbecue
I hate that one that's pretty good that
is the official turn buddy beautiful
that one's weird man it's like citrusy
but like correct kind of tastes like you
know what that's exactly what it would
taste like okay what would Magnus Play
Bishop A6 I don't think he would play
that move Joo I mean you didn't say what
time control pretty good big dog for Cy
if I'm big dog what are
you bigger dog now I now I have to take
take the night yeah yes see took the
night now what do I take with eat a chip
that's what you got eat a freaking
chip oo that's a lot on there oh that's
hidden different you
right
great I'm rolling up my we got the end
game with the chips okay this is which
one do I want okay none of the back I
like how silent psychological battle
nobody's drank milk yet right we like
okay all right word looks different when
you high on
spice oh man that boy hting
different ship's kind of hot to be
sh this definitely getting hot in this
room guys you
didn't turn the thermost set
up oh I took I took a pond Mister oh you
took a pond you did damn bro you
catching
everything oh that's check oh my God was
on time
no
oh oh my god there you go look can we
get that on camera look how much K did
that she don't care about Gotham Jazz
you see that
right goodness you really want to split
this W I will bro I'll do it for you bro
it's for you man you know what I'm
saying I got you big dog you ready for
this
chat hey so the problem is I don't feel
it yet because there's so much spice
already in my mouth so it's probably
going to be like how IM say it creeps up
on you yeah now it's tur to creep up I
feel it I feel it oh man I'm going to go
to the
ambulance I'm going to call them people
right now my hand please no milk no milk
no milk we doing this with no milk no
fing milk James so two brothers we in a
ditch somewhere y explosions all around
no milk we asked do you need a Band-Aid
no I need no milk sir no
milk
I'm going to feel that for a few days
hours I did bro you do I did I did but
you your brain don't work right with all
the spices and stuff no man I can't feel
my
fingers same time next week
say sure that's a
[Music]
date you okay you your eyes were I know
you got the dub there flagging poor Levy
over here but your eyes they paid the
price there I was like good I was I
didn't see that part I was saying cut a
few times like I just help you know it
was H it was it wasn't fun Danny it was
very spicy I've never been more nervous
to film anything in my life cuz I'm I'm
not that good with spice yeah and when I
put that chip the last chip in my mouth
I thought okay I shouldn't let it touch
my tongue I got to like just swallow it
whole yeah then my throat and then I
touched my nose they didn't put they
didn't put that my nose was just you
touch I remember you touch your no I was
just like luckily they made me look
borderline you know redeemable
well the uh you you were more than
borderline redeemable Wesley wants to
redeem his first day of the title match
will he get it done well what do our
what do our odds say we've been checking
in with them as the chess.com stats team
brings it to us daily the odds are not
ever in Wesley's favor right now this is
uh this is more than the The Hunger
Games on the board for these guys this
is uh this is a really uphill battle for
Wesley so will he get it done
it's time for us to throw I've come up
with all the different ways I can to
talk about jumping from Toronto to Oslo
across the sea and uh we're just GNA
we're just going to leave it right there
Tanya Robert and David we're as excited
as everyone else to watch your guys play
bypl take it away we are so pumped in
the studio the moves will be played in
Toronto but we're excited in Oslo and
we're also expecting some spicy chess to
happen uh the winner
$200,000 on the line second place goes
down to 100K so much at stake Wesley a
uphill battle for him David if you were
in Wesley shoes where is your best shot
I think uh the boys out there in Toronto
nailed it he has to attack he has to
forget the nerves forget the occasion
forget the prize money everything just
go for magnus's King yeah and Magnus is
one step away from his third Champions
chess star title how is he feeling today
does he want to wrap this up as quickly
as possible yeah you don't want to give
Wesley that hope that confidence because
a confident Wesley so is a dangerous man
so if Magnus has the chance you want to
put it away in the second set do not
allow it to get to a third yes because
though Wesley has quite the challenge up
in front of him he has to beat Magnus
not once but twice for the title but it
has been done before Robert it has been
done before Wesley beat him earlier to
In This Very event in the round robin
stage and Maxim Vash lra earned his in
the tour finals by beating Magnus twice
in the same day that should give Wesley
some hope but Magnus he doesn't like
losing very much I think he probably
learned his lesson Wesley he needs to
create some of that Maxim magic one more
time in this finals on set one it just
felt and Magnus said it himself that
Wesley was just a little bit too
cautious is Wesley going to try to aim
again to get to Armageddon or he does he
take the battle head on I think uh at
this point Armageddon would be
successful Wesley just judging by the
way he was playing yesterday but that
being said it does feel like he needs to
attack at some point yesterday even when
he got promising positions even in the
final game in a must-win situation he
had an advantage it just felt like he
didn't really believe so uh belief is
everything here uh Magnus he only really
is vulnerable in those positions where
his King is under Fire no more end games
Wesley no more kind of slow uh grinds no
more long deep thinks for no reason save
the time on the clock go for magnus's
King and just hope it pans out he's got
to risk it right now it's the final
chance yeah because Magnus Carlson we
know him he's looking for the smallest
the minutest of inaccuracy he's smelling
when his opponent isn't feeling
confident when he's not believing in
himself and that's the Wesley we saw
yesterday taking some tame tame
decisions on the board which give Magnus
the chance to strike when the
opportunity presented itself it cannot
make even a single mistake at times
against Magnus Carlson and a day ago
yesterday does seem so far away but
Wesley believe in order to be the best
you have to be three the best I don't
think Wesley should do that again maybe
he learned his lesson and Magnus on the
other hand it's been a New Year's
resolution for him 2023 is about to end
if he wants to knock that one out he has
to play B3 today ah will he go for the 1
B3 but maybe he's not got to play for
the memes right now Wesley so I believe
that for him to get to Armageddon would
be a success make things more a random
but on the path to that if you get your
opportunity ities you can't afford to
shy away from them yeah you definitely
cannot take the easy way out this time
no point conserving energy this is the
last game of the whole tour this season
and uh Wesley he does start with white
as well so he needs to show Magnus his
intentions today he cannot play as
conservatively as he has been doing this
first game I think will tell us a lot
will'll tell Magnus a lot and uh I think
he needs to show himself that he can do
it Wesley so it's such a tight rope to
walk on because Wesley has to take the
risks when they do come but if it
backfires it could just be Championship
over Magnus gets one early win and that
that makes a task almost impossible for
Wesley to strike back he is first on the
table perhaps just thinking about these
early moments the opening approach he of
course knows right now what his first
move move number one will be yeah um
often you have planned out your first
few moves you've kind of predicted what
your opponent's going to do and you know
exactly how you'll play the first 5 10
moves but you just have to manifest the
uh of just consider what might happen a
bit later on just envisage those
dramatic situations things are getting
tense how are you going to play how
quickly are you going to react how
confidently are you going to react so
it's not just about this opening stage
for Wesley it's the mindset the attitude
the philosophy with which he approaches
this game he's looking confident right
now and a really good point made there
by you uh David that it's the position
on the board the opening approach and
let's listen in I thought Wesley said
something there but also David yesterday
we witnessed both these players burned
so much time on the clock clock how big
a factor will it be for Wesley to try
and put pressure on the clock as well
and we see Magnus walking in when you
see that man storming your way usually
you run in the other direction Wesley
has to say stay seated and he has to
stay composed so he cannot afford to get
in time trouble the games will begin
soon but it's not fun in games when
you're facing Magnus Carlson it's never
fun but it is a big Challenge and so
much at stake for these two players
Wesley so down a set has to win this set
to take it to the third and the final
one for Magnus gson he is looking for
his third title win in the champion
chestar and we're off we're off and
Wesley so back to 1 B3 surprise here
will Magnus have prepared for this I
mean that looks like a Double Bluff
Robert he made me eat my words yesterday
does not seem so far away because we
have a repeat and for the second day in
a row Magnus pauses he is trying to
collect himself and determine what to
play against this first move so T are
you surprised that Magnus is spending
precious seconds here I am loving this 1
B3 after what happened yesterday though
Wesley did not get into any trouble out
of the opening it was an equal battle
and Magnus choosing a similar setup from
set one the fan catter that we saw David
put yourself in magnus's mind right now
you're facing this 1 B3 we've been
calling it all the playing for the memes
opening how are you reacting well I
think Magnus he's played so many uh meme
type openings throughout his own career
that he'll just uh not be too phased and
uh he will as he's shown in the game so
far just try to react in a similar vein
to yesterday where he just established a
very solid position no real weaknesses
and was able to later equalize um here
play is transposing back towards more
conventional more traditional Waters
white is ready to feo both Bishops so
both Bishops on the longest possible
diagonals for white Magnus has got one
of his own but it will be a fight for
those Central squares so Magnus now just
mulling over uh how to react I think he
just wants solidity Magnus Carlson he
doesn't want to punish Wesley for this
uh opening choice and a good change by
Wesley from a day ago because now he's
fting his light score Bishop first
yesterday Magnus was actually able to
play B6 and Bishop B7 to get his light
score Bishop on the board's longest
diagonal so Wesley is playing a slightly
different move order which has different
consequences they always nuances in
every single turn and you see that
Magnus he's adopting more of a king's
Indian style playing in the center of
the board and Wesley did adopt the 1 B3
against nbec as well it worked to
perfection in that one it was a
miniature by Wesley we saw him play the
same opening in set one against Magnus
that was uh that ended in a draw but no
one I think very few were actually
expecting a repeat of that in set two as
well so Wesley getting the Mind Games
going there and as Robert said for the
light Squad Bishop that Magnus has it's
impossible to Fan C it on B7 like it
happened yesterday so looking at the
other diagonal he pushes the pawn in
front front of the Queen White looking
to expand in the center here at some
point I believe so but as soon as you
expand in the center you restrict the
scope of your Bishops because pawns you
want them in the center and you they
always say bad Bishop usually defends a
good Pawn so you can happily push P
forward excuse me in the center and we
see that Wesley he takes a calmer
approach a little bit of a quieter
approach David does that surprise you at
all very much so and we saw Magnus just
look away from the board briefly after
that move light frown before he goes
back to that Pokerface Magnus Carson but
this one again it feels a bit indecisive
I think Wesley's just trying to stay
flexible but it does allow Magnus to
build in the center Magnus has a bit
more space in the middle of the board
right now with Black's porn formation
Wesley he's just put his KN on a really
really flexible square and watch out for
whites pawns White's D Pawn in the
center White's F Pawn they can challenge
the head of Black's Pawn chain so I like
the approach from wesle so uh it feels
like he's already uh kind of trying to
force himself into this mindset of a
must-win situation but it is a bit
provocative it is a bit risky it is a
full-blooded fight now where having the
advantage of the white pieces having
that extra first move doesn't really
count for too much um so I think reasons
to be happy for both sides it's a real
fight but Wesley he's just trying to
play chess as we say and with the
location of his Knight's development in
front of the king as you were
highlighting David that white has a
choice of which Pawn to push to
challenge for the center I think the F
Pawn will go forward especially once
White Castles and we see mag he's
shaking his head's like all right not so
bad that looks okay but he needs to
figure out a plan because what Wesley is
doing is he's mixing things up and he's
also securing a lead on the clock and
we've seen in most games the player that
has the advantage in terms of how much
time they have left that's usually pay
dividends for them and Magnus preempts
the opening up of the E Line places his
Rook on the eall continues with
development also keeping the flexibility
for the Queens side pieces to come out
where you want to place them because
we've been talking about that that light
Square Bishop that Wesley has on G2 you
often want to blunt that with the c Pawn
moving one step ahead C6 to make sure
that the diagonal remains blocked the
big questions will happen in this
position once Wesley strikes with the F
Pawn forward uh with F4 if he delays
that too much Magnus can start thinking
about breaking in the center with D5
himself yeah Magnus is at least hinting
but uh kind of towards that plan and it
does feel like blacks may be more ready
for action to happen than white right
now um I must admit I'm surprised W liso
hasn't castled his King but he might be
fearing uh your move there Tanya Black's
Pawn coming to D5 so things to starting
to get a bit more concrete it's not just
about where the pieces are going it's
also about specific plans if I start my
plan how does black react and uh kind of
what are the consequences of those moves
and Wesley now in the tank I think this
is a good moment to pause uh we will see
a flurry of moves surely over the next
few turns but um yeah Wesley so he
definitely feels like he's come swinging
come fighting in these early stages so
far far
yeah really fun start and Promises to be
a spicy spicy game one off set two and
earlier we saw Levy and James in their
chili battle David you had won against
Magnus how hot did that get yeah that
was uh one of the worst days of my life
I've got to say Tanya about two years
ago on the on I think season one of the
Champions chess tour uh I did have this
chili match against Magnus and he loves
spicy food I hate spicy food I just
can't handle it at all and he forced the
Queens off really on he was literally
tra kind of chasing my queen around the
board forcing me to trade them off just
so I had to eat the spiciest uh uh kind
of punishment there and yeah he he took
me down how many days in a roow did you
have the sweats uh it was a few I must I
downed a few pints of milk uh literally
within minutes because my mouth was on
fire and uh yeah that's the problem with
Magnus he's good at chess he's good at
eating spicy food is good everything is
there a video of this out there like can
I go watch this during the break maybe
on YouTube
so everybody at home all of you out
there go find that chili chess challenge
between David Howell and Magnus Carlson
and let me know what happened because I
have to do this show I can't watch it
just
yet W Magnus Carlson so competitive
regardless of the situation and playing
some Mind Games in Chile chess as well
and we see some upcoming Mind Games in
this one about Central breaks in this
position we were discussing this move
earlier so Magnus really getting ready
for D5 he's getting ready to beat things
up to make it spicy as you said Tanya
and uh I think he's ready for that he's
always ready for uh play to become a bit
fiery Wesley so meanwhile yet to make a
decision again uh burning quite a lot of
time on the clock now and this might be
the moment to strike in the center uh
for Wesley with one of those Pawn pushes
we've been talking about whether it be
the white D Pawn in front of the White
Queen whether it's the white F Pawn
because if you do Castle black expands
in the center and I can't Envision White
Ever Getting Any opening Advantage there
if anything white might have to be be
careful to hold the balance I'm with you
and I think that if Wesley wants to
strike in the center with his own D Pawn
that Magnus is not going to initiate any
trades I do believe that trading the
center would only help White's cause so
he would thrust his ewn forward and then
create a pawn chain towards the center
and when you have a pawn chain you want
to attack in the direction of your Pawn
chain so if black has a pawn chain from
the queen side heading towards the
center then you want to go and aim
towards the king side and for white if
he pushes this Pawn to D4 his Pawn chain
is going in the other direction it's
going towards the center from F2 to D4
you want to play on the queen side so
look at the direction of your Pawn chain
that should indicate where you're
heading where pieces should go really
instructive there Robert and we're on
move eight we're already talking about
pawn braks and we have a very very
different decision by Wesley on the
board it's not D4 it's not F4 it's the
pawn that we haven't been talking about
it's moved twice up the board he's not
fighting for his own breakes but he's
fighting against magnus' breakes of D5
yeah I think this is a good move
actually a good decision in Practical
terms he's made magnus's plans less
clear now by blocking up the center but
in the back of his mind Wesley will be
kicking himself he'll be saying why
didn't I put this Pawn on e4 a few moves
ago uh stepping one square with a pawn
and then two three moves later pushing
it again is a clear waste of a Tempo and
in chess it's all about time it's all
about saving moves you've simply wasted
one move and will that come back to
haunt you it's unclear but uh Wesley
maybe just uh kind of annoyed at his own
indecision earlier and now that the
light scor Bishop for white that
diagonal is closed down Magnus can play
for this B5 Pawn push because his rook
in the corner is safe thanks to the
placement of the E4 Pawn so A6 is a move
play to expand on the queen side for
Magnus if Wesley plays Pawn A4 up two
squares to stop that B5 push then Magnus
will push the a pawn a second time in a
row and this is a bit high level this is
what Magnus Carlson does best is he
forces his opponent to make a hole in
the position create a weak Ness and he
will then exploit it and he's forcing
Wesley to burn time on the clock as well
we're still in the early stage of the
game and of course the critical moments
will arise later for which these seconds
these minutes are super important on the
board now it's move number nine we've
seen Wesley slow down the last two moves
is it fair to call these pawn moves
these committal moves that he's making
with white critical
decisions yes and no Pawn pushers they
always kind of Define the outline the
skeleton of any position so it's always
critical when to push them when to just
hold the line when to uh kind of just
yeah when to stay or uh kind of trade
off basically which Wesley has a dilemma
here after this B5 Pawn push but then
again it feels like the critical moments
are ahead it feels like all the pieces
are still on the board the tactics are
still miles off uh so you ideally want
to save a bit of time yes these porn
pushes are worth contemplating they
worth investing 20 30 seconds maximum
but he's spending much more than that
it's minutes on every move move and
right now Robert your move on the board
uh this Pawn to B5 push what should
Wesley be doing it's tough It's Not Easy
not instinctive striking in the center
now with Pawn to D4 it feels like you
lost a Tempo because white did push the
PA to E3 only then to play E4 and these
Tempe in the opening stage that's what
gives white the first move Advantage so
if you're losing that first move because
you've moved a piece twice that will
help black at minimum equalize and
Wesley plays A3 so he's stopping Black
from pushing the pawn and any further
but he's playing on the flank so still
no Central decisions on this board and I
feel like Magnus he can continue his
develop in a very natural way there's no
pressure in his position yeah was he
closing his eyes there Wesley so I'm not
sure whether that's meditation or
whether that's just like I'm playing
moves I really don't want to be playing
right now because A3 feels a bit loose
feels a bit weak it's reacting to the
opponent rather than dictating the pace
himself and it's Magnus now who can
start gaining time I'm expecting his
Bishop to come out out no he brings his
Knight out instead and uh yeah it feels
like actually black here because wh's
wasted a move early in the opening by
pushing a pawn twice black is
essentially playing an opening that
white would be wanting to play and yeah
I think uh psychologically Advantage
Magnus right now a good outcome uh from
the opening by Magnus uh we've got more
we've got reinforcements coming in from
Toronto as Levy is with Fabby to break
this down for us guys to us it feels
like very guarded play by West so far
what do you
think thanks Tanya yeah Fabby what is
your impression of the opening first of
all Wesley going back to B3 and second
of all Wesley playing whatever this is
yeah well when you play B3 you're sort
of accepting an element of Randomness
because you don't know what type of
position you're going to get uh like we
see here it's it's a kind of standard
sort of thing you could get in the
English kings Indian setup for Black uh
neither side has the advantage for sure
uh but I would I would recommend if
someone wants to to try to beat Magnus
in a match to put maximum pressure on
and this is really not the ideal way to
do it I mean it's a very comfortable
position for
black so I'm not sure if the opening
approach is the best one uh but you know
it's anyway these games will come down
to who's playing better it's usually not
coming down to the opening let me just
follow up on that um this position that
we have on the screen is this do you
think this is a conscious decision by
Wesley over the last 24 hours to go yeah
I think this is my best chance or is
this a result of overthinking and going
no D4 or maybe E4 or maybe like I and
just going to this as a last resort well
Wes Wesley is a bit of a mystery to me
as a as a chess player as a person as
well he is uh he's a little bit of a
mystery he's very much a player who like
thrives on positive emotions and maybe
he feels like playing B3 and having a
bit of fun is the way to get those
positive emotions I don't think it's a
strategic choice in terms of like like
this is the best way to get an advantage
against Magnus because the best way to
do that is is definitely to put pressure
in the most direct way possible and then
Magnus generally speaking he never shies
away from a fight so this this is what
happened in our match um I was like
welcoming the fight and he was also
welcoming the fight and we got very
complicated positions uh because that's
what we both wanted while here it's it's
kind of a slow approach to the opening
it's definitely not how I would approach
the match like I I wouldn't do this I'm
not saying it's a bad approach but uh
yeah never in a million years would I
think this is the best way to win the
match when's the last time you played B3
with white I mean probably like a few
days ago online okay but like in a one
of these Magnus you know Wesley Hikaru
like yeah I've never gotten the B3 hype
so I I've never really played it in a
serious game have you played in a
classical game ever I not as far as I
know maybe a long time ago but wow um
wow it's like I like to experiment but I
feel like B3
isn't um isn't really the way to get an
exciting position if you want to
experiment on the other hand a lot of
people have put in serious theoretical
work into B3 like if you the theory
really expanded and kind of exploded at
some point a few years ago uh probably
because people got bored or just
disillusioned with trying to fight
against the main uh like defenses in E4
and D4 so they thought okay I'll at
least I'll get a fresh position I'll
analyze it I'll know it better than my
opponent and um and we'll get a game and
the thing is that usually people were
playing like B3 E5 when sometimes things
get exciting yeah but if people just
play like B3 B6 then you actually just
get a boring position or B3 G6 things
like that if if black tries to get
ambitious then we then you really have a
fight on your hands speaking of ambition
I guess we have the technically that was
the first capture of the game Magnus
just took on C4 a lot of Wesley
repositioning The Rook to B1 where the
Knight used to stand and then the bishop
into the into the corner where the Rook
used to be um I don't I can't quite read
what the plan is is the plan to just
kind of wave a a red flag in front of a
charging bull and sort of bring Magnus
to him like how okay he's going to he's
taking back with the B Pawn I think this
is just a bad decision I'm actually
shocked by bc4 like DC4 okay you get you
get an unbalanced position you try to
play Queen C2 Rook D1 and B4 eventually
and then B5 and try to get the D5 Square
this is just worse because after the
trade on B1 or you can even not trade
you can play Bishop B6 you never get D4
because C4 is so weak so the Knight on
C5 is is a Eternal Outpost pretty much
uh you have a worse structure because
you have C4 D3 E4 instead of C D6 D6 E5
so D6 is our weakness D3 is okay he can
play Bishop B6 now Queen C7 Rook B8 he
follows up like that um like you're
never you're never improving this it's
just a worse position just like a very
very sad position for white um while if
he had taken DC maybe his worry was that
Bishop B6 and A5 A4 comes and C4 gets
undermined but still you you just have
to do that and you have to take the
double edge chance that yeah maybe it
goes wrong but uh but okay it's a big
fight here you're just dooming yourself
to passivity with white so I think that
was a really strange and and really not
a very good decision from Wesley and
last question before we throw it back to
osel you've played Magnus many many
times um you do you think he senses the
hesitation the slightly subpart
decision- making and and I mean he he's
not going to play it safe like he he
will just build up until a moment where
he can make a break and just try to win
game one with black yeah this is well I
think any player but especially Magnus
would recognize this as a moment to
strike you get a comfortable edge with
black no real risk uh easy easy natural
decision so you don't even have to spend
much time or get into time trouble and
yeah a win with black in the first game
is like putting yourself in a huge
position to win the match so uh the
question is can white get D4 sack C4 and
then get some play I I I don't see it
happening I think he can just play like
Queen C7 here take over the B file um of
course white remains solid but yeah I I
would assume Magnus sees this as an
opportunity to
strike all right thank you Fabiano we're
going to send it back to Tanya David and
Robert take it away guys love you if we
still have you with Fabby I just wanted
to check in with one question for him
that he mentioned that he would have
perhaps taken some different decisions
from the ones Wesley did uh a different
approach what would be his approach in
such a
situation well but you you saw you saw
my
Approach I played a match against Magnus
I mean it was it didn't work out I I did
I did lose uh the matches but um but I
think my Approach was correct I mean I I
took the fight with black uh also with
white I was playing very com combative
lines it resulted in like a relatively
low quality but I think that was a
result of the complexity of the
positions that we aimed for uh so like
my choices with with black especially
like to play the Archangel and this
bishop G4 line were like a very clear
sign I think that I wanted to get pretty
much the most complex positions and um
yeah the Armageddon didn't go well but
my my strategy for the Armageddon and my
play was just actually my strategy was
okay my play was just very very bad in
Armageddon but let me ask you if we just
take the rapid portion of the two
matches that you played against Magnus
like are you're probably happy with what
you got right I mean Armageddon is a
totally what different Beast with the
time discrepancy the draw odds like it's
a completely different format really I
mean would would you agree with that or
you kind of have to just be able to
manage it all in one flow yeah no I I I
think the strategy worked out and uh
everything that I went into with the
matches were was good like my mindset
was good um I was ready for a fight I
was actually feeling pretty confident it
was only some decisions at critical
moments and some mistakes at critical
moments that ultimately doomed me in
those matches uh in Armageddon but also
like in the first match especially yeah
some decisions uh not winning the second
game in the second match losing the
first game in the first match yeah not
drawing with white pieces in a in a must
draw game like there's a lot of things I
can regret but none of it comes down to
um my decision making before the match
it was all stuff in the moment which
very often is difficult I mean you can't
really strategize for things that happen
in the Heat of the Moment you can get
your general strategy and then um
hopefully you have you pick a good one
that's that's always a difficult
question you never know if like you play
a risky line it ends in disaster and
you're like well of course I shouldn't
have done that but that's always in Hind
those things are easy to say um also in
hindsight I I chose a risky risky
strategy it worked out and it's easy to
say it was a good one but of course it
could have also gone the other way uh
but generally speaking I think um what I
did was was correct like I I got Magnus
in positions that he's not 100%
confident in maybe I'm also not 100%
confident but I was I was ready for that
um uh sort of mutual discomfort that we
got Fabby we got you on here quick
question for you Fabby no we're still
was we'll say the whole time you said
you don't regret decisions that you made
but do you regret kind of encouraging
Wesley to play 1 B3 we all saw what was
happening back and forth between you
two no the thing is I didn't encourage
him to play B3 I because Magnus had his
list of goals which I actually see right
here on the Whiteboard and they're all
okay L's getting them so they're all
supposed to be for this this tour and
one of them uh he got all of them right
I I I gave him one of them is he having
do we know that did we confirm that
confirm that he's having
fun okay well he confirmed I don't know
like he needs to get this last one so I
was like just prepare for it because you
you're going to get B3 in this match um
but Magnus is not going for B3 maybe
maybe he's uh he's jinxing or not
jinxing he's he's tricking Everyone by
saying he's going to play B3 and then
not actually doing it we need just
sponsor on here it's what we
need all right thanks guys and uh Fabby
we hope to see you again on the
broadcast if you have some time Jump in
whenever lby thanks for that we'll keep
checking in with you guys and meanwhile
there is uh there are moves that have
happened some trades uh some decisions
fixing of bond structure a queen trade
decline but it looks like Wesley is
under pressure here he's the one who's
on the back foot this looks really bad
for white and exactly a Magnus type of
position and the eval bar is suggesting
that black is way ahead and it's even
material and the reason why is look at
how active the black queen is the White
Queen sitting passively defending a pawn
the Knight on C5 for black it's peering
in the white Camp hitting this D3 Pawn
as well and normally when you have this
backwards Pawn you want to push it but
if you push the D Pawn down goes the C
Pawn at the end of the line so I feel
like there are too many weaknesses in
this position for Wesley he's very
passive the B file the only open file is
under Black's control it looks like it's
going to be magnus's game yeah so many
improving moves for Magnus CS right now
you can occupy the B file with your Rook
you can relocate well he beat me to it
Magnus Carson there I was going to say
you can relocate this Black Knight out
the way now you kind of indirectly
control this Square even further making
it totally impossible for white to
consider pushing this Pawn forward to D4
at the right moment black can just start
expanding on the queen side maybe black
has Pawn breaks as well with F5 later
but uh yeah it just feels like oneway
traffic and how can Wesley so break out
it just looks like he's almost Frozen
this bishop stuck in the corner the
White Queen stuck defending this m Pawn
on A3 and okay he decides to go for it
right now I said it was almost
impossible but maybe he sensed Wesley
the momentum was turning so much that he
needed to go for this and at least
there's a hit on the C6 Pawn as well as
the black queen right now so Magnus has
a decision to make does he simply drop
back the queen I think the most natural
decision right now or does he get greedy
there's also the option of perhaps
taking this KN uh in and then winning
this Pawn but I think I would be
reluctant to go for this because
suddenly this bishop which landed on
this diagonal as early as move to has
potential it has chances on the dark
squares so right now I'm expecting
magnus's Queen to drop back and okay
game on Wesley did maybe find a good
moment because not quite enough time for
Magnus to capture this week porn on C4 I
like this decision that you're pointing
out fall back with the queen I saw the
evalar did not react to the trade of the
bishop with the Knight on D4 but is just
doesn't feel like the human approach in
this position you give up a dark Squad
Bishop that White Queen can at some
point land on to 86 you're looking at
that Bishop from A1 Spitting Fire Down
the diagonal yes you're counting at a
knight block from the center of the
board perhaps the F Pawn moving forward
but unless it's based on some direct
calculation direct tricks Bishop takes
Knight is never a decision you want to
take it's extremely risky and we already
see the makings of a checkmating attack
if you line your queen up with that dark
Square bishop and there are some tactics
that will help blackout for example if
this black queen goes all the way back
to B8 it protects the pawn and threatens
Knight B3 a fork of not even just the
queen in The Rook but also that Bishop
in the corner which is the threatening
piece so if Magnus if he calculates just
one move ahead because so many of us
would we' refuse this line on the spot I
can't allow that dark Square Bishop
looming just sitting back on A1 but I
think he actually get rid of that piece
very quickly in which case this is going
to be a better Pawn structure for him
and the advantage that's a really
important point because you see Bishop
takes Knight and somehow there's a
psychological Block in chess players to
make such a move giving up this powerful
ship for the night and Magnus calculates
it he finds it and he goes for the best
move he goes for the best move whether
it's the best follow-up is unclear so
far because he didn't drop back the
black queen as looked really really
strong Right There He has blocked The
Bishop's diagonal however he has moved
in for the kill of the C4 Pawn uh so
still Advantage black but Wesley he's
given himself some chances and um look
at the clock times it's not over yet uh
far from it Wesley so I think he played
the best practical Choice pushing D4
there before it was too late before he
was just eternally passive and um it's
just about whether he can somehow trick
Magnus now break through the barrier of
the Black Knights and most players would
prefer to be upon PA down for some
activity you don't want to sit passively
which is what Wesley's position looked
like before he decided to strike with D4
so it was a good decision a needed
decision from Wesley he grabs his Pawn
on D6 and the C4 Pawn is loose but
Magnuson said he hops his Knight forward
there may be some threats not just
against this queen but also the king
that two Pawn is a bit vulnerable that
Knight on D3 that's a really strong
piece and you pointed out the threats
against the white king potentially the
queen there's also the A3 Pawn that the
White Queen cannot stay connected to you
move that Queen anywhere I'm picking up
that A3 Pawn I'm attacking that Rook on
D6 winning more Temple yeah actually
this Rook is pretty much trapped this
Rook doesn't have too many safe squares
apart from dropping back to D4 suddenly
blocking your own Bishop's diagonal but
maybe there's a way to round up this
rook in the middle I don't really see it
right now but still looks very strong
for Magnus Carson and Wesley he's about
to choose a safe Square for his Queen
not many options he actually slides it
across to D1 instead and the evaluation
bar drops with that move I think your
your idea there Tanya take this Pawn
restore the material balance is pretty
much guaranteed and uh unfortunately for
white you cannot take this knight uh
because you cannot take a second time on
D3 your queen is stuck protecting the
bishop in the corner so black would win
material so this Rook is in a bit of
trouble right now if Magnus Garson takes
this point and Wesley saw yesterday said
that it's inexcusable in a mini match to
lose a game with the white pieces this
one he's got to be extremely careful
it's big advantage to Magnus right now
and Magnus grabs that pawn so material
equality and look at Wesley he jettison
the pawn he's going to lose it anyway
but plays C5 perhaps he wants to
distract some of Black's pieces in fact
if that Queen takes the pawn then that
tactic that David was mentioning no
longer works The Rook can successfully
take this Knight on D3 you get two
nights for your sacrificed Rook that
would be a good exchange but the engine
does not seem to approve with Wesley's
decision it says that black is in the
driver seat the B file is still open for
the black Rook to slide over and it
feels like as long as you're careful
here for Magnus Whit's pieces are not
very harmonious there should be a tactic
in magus's favor yeah at first glance if
you just showed me this position in a
void out of the blue I would say it's
messy I wouldn't know who was better who
had the advantage so the computer shows
that the valuation bar shows that
magnus's last move might also kind of
reinforce that fact and it's due to the
fact that White Queen is simply
overloaded really beautiful deflection
idea from Magnus he attacks the queen on
D1 and he's also eyeing that Rook on D6
which looks well defended for the moment
but if you play a move like Queen to B1
I think Knight takes F2 is one of the
ideas here if the king takes an F2 Queen
takes C5 with check the Rook is in
trouble the Kings also might just get
checkmated if King F1 for example Bishop
C4 check interm met so that looks
painful so you might not even need to
win the material just win the game by
delivering a Checkmate Wesley his pieces
are all over the place I don't think you
can defend them all this looks
absolutely busted and yes you can keep
the queen connected to the F2 Pawn but
like you said the queen is overloaded
even if the queen was to go to F1 I
think the tactics just flow and fall
into place because yes after Knight
takes Pawn you can pick that pawn Knight
up with the queen but watch out that
Bishop on A1 is hanging everything's
falling apart not just the bishop
hanging this Knight would then drop next
move all the loose pieces in White's
Camp are just falling apart and Wesley
he does play this move but I think you
mentioned it Tanya knockout blow Knight
takes F2 just shedding uh the king of
its uh protection here and yeah maybe
this multiple moves Bishop C4 looks very
tempting lining up against the queen
other ideas in the air it feels just too
loose for white and Black's pieces
especially the Queen Bishop and Knight
here too strong they've infiltrated
Behind Enemy Lines the hope for white
was that there would be a dark Square
attack but that attack's not even
getting off the ground and the move
Queen F1 it seems to take away Knight
takes F2 but as Tanya brilliantly just
showed there the tactic still works in
Black's favor so it's one of these
things where multiple white pieces
defend the square black doesn't have any
more Firepower aiming at it but because
White's pieces are scattered and they
all needed to protect one another Knight
takes F2 is a beautiful shot but as
David said even a simple Bishop slide
Bishop back to C4 or Bishop to C2 these
moves will still be good and yeah he
moves Bishop to C4 it's I think the most
natural move if you don't see the tactic
on F2 yeah and big threats White's Rook
we've been talking about it it's pretty
much trapped Black's Queen is going to
come back and take the pawn we mentioned
on C5 white is stuck white is passive
and H this again it feels like it's just
a continuation of the narrative Wesley
being passive making negative decisions
look at that White Queen next to its
white king it's stem it stemmed from the
opening simply he was just playing
really tentatively not really wanting to
play uh kind of principled moves and now
he's just being punished threat is
stronger than its exec Magnus Carlson
keeps all the threats on the board
against the C5 Pawn tactics on F2 and
Wesley so in deep trouble with just a
minute on the clock but Magnus as well
coming down to those seconds he needs to
finish this he does and I think he can
steal the pawn on C5 that's step one
that white Rook can barely Escape it was
a good point to note that that Rook
doesn't have very many moves remaining
but I'm curious what Magus is thinking
about is he looking for a followup or is
he actually looking to end the game on
the spot something tactical whereas he
can just snag the pawn and be happy yeah
it feels like Magnus now his clock time
is the main thing uh it is Wesley so's M
major hope right now it's the only thing
that could trip him up Magnus Carson
because just take a Pawn off the board
you're up on material there we go he
captures forcing the white Rook back to
an awkward Square here clumsy square and
as sooner or later Magnus can start
pushing pawns Magnus can improve his
Rook still he has fantastic pieces here
as black maybe he's looking too much for
a knockout blow he doesn't need anything
immediate he's got a long-term Advantage
down under 20 seconds this is a messy
position he moves his Queen back from
the square came from which was a good
decision the evaluation bar on the left
hand side of the board it approves so
Tanya the time 20 seconds are you
getting nervous for Magnus or do you
still think is everything under control
I think it's chaos still you've got so
many minor pieces and that Bishop on A1
as long as it's alive you've got to
watch out for any kind of uh threats
building up against the uh black king
right now Wesley just creating a lift
Square for his own King but magnus's
pieces are so dominating he does fall
back with the Knight feels like because
of the pressure on the clock he's not
making the absolute best choices but
still enough to keep things under
control enough for now but he has kind
of wasted a bit of time with the black
queen he's retr the Black Knight back
that was his best piece but look at the
nerves from Wesley so he reached out
about to make a move then tried to hide
it and yeah the nerves are kicking in
now it's the first game of the day the
first game is always the most nervy for
both of them as they Tred to get back in
the zone Wesley finds a great move
trying to trade off the Queens White's
Queen was passive Black's Queen was
active those pieces off the board and he
can breathe the S of relief so great
move Magnus reluctantly look at magnus's
face suddenly under 10 seconds yeah he's
5 seconds on the clock he does trade the
Queens he does have the extra Pawn but
watch out for that Bishop there that
Bishop on A1 gives white long-term
compensation Black's Rook stuck on the
last rank defending any checks of rook
d8 and now Wesley gets rid of that
Knight the key Knight on E5 that was
blocking the bishop on A1 Wesley moving
forward for the initiative but I love
the way that Magnus is playing this
because now all of his pieces are
defended so he can push his pass a pawn
Wesley has that under control for now
but Magnus with no time on his clock
he's making sure that some of his
decisions will be easier he will not
blunder a piece at least not yet yeah
the last five six moves have gone in Wes
Leo's favor in terms of surviving not
losing on the spot but Magnus is still
safe Magnus still has the extra Pawn
Wesley still nervous retreating there
with the white Rook not sure whether he
could have kept it active or not uh
either way now he
should be trying to use this momentum he
should be trying to create threats as he
just does against Black's Bishop which
is slightly loose and Magnus countering
by trying to infiltrate with a black
Rook down to the first Rank and White's
dark Square Bishop is kind of Trapped
over there so Knight D3 played
apparently a huge mistake and Magnus
pushes his Pawn giving up his Bishop to
win a knight it's a winning Advantage
because the bishop on A1 is trapped and
Wesley's over with two seconds on the
clock makes a move he gives a check
comes back with the Rook there's panic
and Magnus picks up another Pawn wow
Wesley so missed that one frustration
visible on his face there now two point
Advantage for black and White's
remaining pawns are dropping off three
point Advantage for black this one is
winning for Magnus no time Wesley so he
made that move with one second left and
the black king is too safe Wesley barely
getting his moves up and you can see his
body language he's pretty much resigned
before he tipped the king over he saves
his Bishop but those pass pawns for
black they should end the game Magnus
gaining time with with every move 3
second increment everybody it's bonus
time and those Knights they're hopping
in and now with the trades when you're
head material you're happy to see Pieces
come off the board and you can see the
relief on Magnus he knows that he's so
close to this one that Rook will jump to
the second rank giving a check the pawns
are Marching forward and with the dark
Square Bishop gone black king in
absolute safety and we're going to see
the pawns make their way towards White
Camp F3 coming in and Wesley looks like
he's almost on the brink of giving up
you just have to watch out for one
threat that ewn six is something that
you need to keep under check yeah and
Magnus okay he moves his King but he
didn't have too much time either still
not over this game Wesley so he's got
one of the pawns back wh's eorn still
alive can he keep the tricks going and
white porn marches but I think Magnus
has spotted a nice trick here he will be
able to stop this white porn from
promotion oh that's beautiful
recognition from M giving that check so
The Rook can stop the pawn and Wesley
now his hopes are pretty much dashed
black has what three extra Pawns in a
rook end game yeah and that E Pawn Stop
the Aon marches forward and Wesley knows
that this is all over it's Unstoppable
he will have to give up that ewn he
tries to create tricks and he gives up
Wesley so resigns Magnus Carlson takes
the lead in set two what a game with the
black pieces getting the initiative
Wesley guarded playing kg at the
beginning and that seemed to cost him a
lot I think it was a overly cautious
play from Wesley so he wanted just a
position where he could try to outplay
Magnus Carlson but look at this man does
he look like someone who gets outplayed
very easily the answer is absolutely not
so Magnus opened one file that was
enough to gain the initiative he ended
up making wh's pieces scattered and
that's why he leads in this second set
one game to none Magnus Carlson with the
lead which means Wesley so has to First
equalize the score then look for his win
to take it to set three the task get
more and more impossible how do you make
this Mission possible for Wesley now
it's going to be so tough losing with
white is the most heartbreaking thing as
a chess professional it's demoralizing
he knows he lost with white yesterday as
well at the moment Wesley it feels like
he woke up halfway through that game
started playing great Fighting Chess but
it was too late and that might break his
confidence it's going to be hard it's
going to be so tough yeah Wesley is not
only fighting the best player on the
planet but his own right now given the
matth situation this is looking close to
impossible for me right now Wesley
himself said it losing a game with the
white pieces is absolute disaster David
he started slow but where did Magnus
manage to strike well Magnus managed to
work his magic in the middle game we saw
Magnus pick up a few pawns White's
position was too passive too loose and
Magnus was able to cash in but it was
the closing stages that magnus's pure
endgame magic really really sh shined
through and it was these final stages
black was three pawns up we' pretty much
written it off this game these black
pawns have stepped far down the board
close to promotion now but there's a
threat of white porn stepping forward
the remaining chance for Wesley so and
the style in which Magnus uh was able to
turn this in his favor was really
impressive King to G6 first of all
stepping out of this seventh Rank and
after a check King activity in end games
he steps forward even further and it was
here hunting down the white Bishop the
Magnus calculated accurately with no
time on his clock to E6 is scary white
now two squares away from touchdown but
after taking this bishop this Pawn is
stoppable and this check another check
now from the Black Knight and finally a
rook slide clinched this game for Magnus
Carlson the pawn was under lock and key
yes he had to part with his Knight but
black has too many pawns and soon won
the game there were multiple moments in
that endgame stretch where Magnus
protected indirectly instead of putting
a piece to defend the piece under attack
he slid his Rook on over then at the end
there he stopped the pass Pawn thanks to
that that tactical execution so Magnus
even though he was getting low on the
clock he showed that he still had
everything under control and Nobody Does
it Better Than Magnus
Carlson it got chaotic but Magnus
Carlson once again showing why he is the
world number one and right now whether
you're a Magnus fan or a Wesley fan
you've got to be a chess fan with all
the action that we're seeing and Danny
is in the fan Zone in Toronto Danny
what's the vibe after that game one
action
action I'm going to ask the crowd what's
the vibe after Magnus got game
one I think we had a lot of fans when it
went down in real action seems to be a
lot of Magnus fans here maybe because he
spend so much time hanging with these
guys the chess bras but okay
heartbreaking for Wesley so as Magnus
Carlson continues to dominate pretty
much every game of chess he plays and
we're changing the game of chess here we
got live fans we're doing stuff that's
maybe never been done before in chess
and we think chess can change the world
on that note I'm going to throw to
what's going to be our next big event
after this it's chess.com chess fora we
partnered with tunai an aoya and chess
and slums Africa to do something that's
never been done we're trying to get
5,000 scholarships for kids in Africa
you can go to go. chess.com fora for
more I'm going to let tunday tell you
what's going to happen when Kasa Corley
Maurice Ashley and others join him for
the event on December 22nd hello
everyone my name is t and I'm the
founder of Chess in STS Africa a
nonprofit organization that uses the
game of chess as a tool to give children
living in a prish communities access to
education in the last 5 years we have
impacted the lives of over 10,000
children but we want to do so much more
this is where I'm happy to announce that
we're joining forces with chess.com to
launch a fundraising campaign chess for
a cost chess for everyone our goal is to
raise money to support the education of
5,000 children next year to help them
get back to school in Nigeria alone
there are over 20 million children that
do not have access to education want to
help solve this problem so we are
launching a tournament on chess.com that
you can participating and some of the
top players in the world would also
participate in it as well the best way
to support this you can share on your
social media you can tell your friends
about this you can participate in the
tournaments if you're a lover of Chess
let us make every move count for the
dreams of those children because we
believe they have the capacity for
greatness thank you very much let's
go
[Applause]
[Music]
I I lost audio by the
way I don't have audio from the
phone I don't know if I'm live or
not that is a live broadcast for you we
could see uh all the fanone action in
Toronto that's happening so if you're in
the city you're missing out get yourself
at the Belfast Pub that's where it's
happening and you can also get your
hands on this beautiful beautiful
displayed of the trophy it's an nftd and
only one other person will have that and
that will be the winner of the Champions
chest so bid for your uh displayed on
chess jams. and you get the only other
special Fan
Edition and that's not all the action
continues after the Champions chest T
Final on December 18th mark your
calendars as Levy he took the chili
challenge first and now he's taking on
another feisty challenge against fosty
Oro you can watch the 10-year-old fosty
take on Gotham chess use the command
stars for all details on that event and
we've got a big game two for Wesley so
coming up will he strike against the
world number one who just looks like
he's impossible to beat right now we
will be back with the action in just a
[Music]
few hi I'm D chess and I'm here
with MV
Denise um uh sorry can we start again
Magnus who is famous from uh Lev's
YouTube videos what would you rate chess
player on a scale of 1 to 10 I'll have
to rate him a 10 9.99 10 if you have to
rate yourself on a scale of 1 to 10 as a
chess player what would it be if Man
10 six but but then what about me Dennis
I'll raate myself a 10 probably
9.7 9.7 do you think others would agree
I think so I don't really care if they
agree or not okay how many beers would
you need to drink for me to beat you in
a classical chess game we at least I
istically to be for you to become the
favorite I think uh six or seven PS
probably start with 20 and take it from
there 20 okay how what's the size of the
cup pints wow okay well I I've never
passed out from drinking beer so I don't
know what my limit is whatever that is
we're I think we're looking at that
number 10 I think I'd still be pretty
fine after 10 20 20 beers well if I'm
awake after
20 I've been really trashed and still
able to play decently how much money
would you need to be paid to try chess
boxing a million um $10 million I can
try even for for free almost annoying
person or of course say the better
question is is there a chess player you
would like to punch in the face don't
say me
please okay not yet we're going to
describe top chess players in one word
Magnus Carlson C hikaro
Nakamura hikaro Levy roswin Levy I don't
I don't want to say this to your face
you know we're going to play chest
player or Ikea furniture sodum okay
definitely Ikea srum as s
s I'm going to say that's sest yes
Swedish which is why it's yeah I mean
it's obviously Swedish really chess
player oh really yep oh my God
ostano okay I feel like I've even seen
this one like here okay I'm going to go
with Furniture I'm really not sure I'm
good chess player it is IKEA
furniture
zbi oh I played this guy I'm here zbi
that's got to be a chest player
whoa but you know what I think it's a
just at least I'm good at something yeah
20 beers
holy a new opening for your wall is here
Capt capure new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a tool-free magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
[Music]
things
and if you're in any of these cities you
are missing out on some big action find
the chess club in your city or the chess
Bob where there are watch bodies going
on don't watch this epic final by
ourselves get your friends get your
loved ones and join the action around
the world and watch chess together and
talking about partying and celebrating
one of our viewers is got big reasons to
party and celebrate as he wins a Magnus
Carlson signed secret lab gaming chair
congratulations to Matt Gil our big big
winner of the secret lab chair and there
will be a big big winner at the end of
today and right now Magnus won a big
game Ka catches up with
him he takes the lead in the second
match Magnus big parts of this game just
incredible would you agree yeah I I I
think I played well for quite a while
and then it became a mess at the end
like my play in the scramble was so bad
but
um yeah uh overall good one what's your
analysis of Wesley who we know he has to
win this match against you does he seem
nervous to you yeah he felt a bit shaky
in this in this game I think uh he was
on the back foot very early on and he
fought back fairly fairly well uh and I
I mean I didn't convert as cleanly as I
as I could but um no he seemed a bit
shaky in general you're getting very
close now to your third consecutive
Champions chest or title is that in your
head at all now or you just thinking
about next game no obviously getting
this one was um was big uh so yeah I
haven't thought too much about it just
try and go out and play more good chess
good luck in the next one thank you
thank you yeah Magnus cars and he will
have the white pieces in the next one
and well we all know what we're hoping
for 1 B3 that's the last goal on his
list to finish in 2023 Champions chestor
season so will we see 1 B3 from Magnus
in the next
game classic Magnus that gets this big
win with the black pieces in set two but
still not happy with his play some
sometimes Magnus he's his biggest
critique and he always finds reasons
that he could have played better that's
why he's the goat that's I think same
with uh every top Sportsman they have to
push themselves it's all about these
incremental advantages incremental
Improvement and he's always looking for
that next level I think it's the same
with any strong chess player Robert and
as we saw when FAO Carana played against
Magnus very little separates them so you
have to push yourself because there it's
such a fine line the little details so
you're going to be upet that you didn't
play every move perfectly as a chess
player with engines out there you know
what the perfect move everyone at home
can play better than Magnus Carlson by
accessing their engine so I think the
players they always want to find the
best move each and every turn Magnus
Carlson relieved but critical of his
conversion in game one but he does get
the big set Le and I'm lead and I'm
thinking about what Fabby said about the
approach to play against Magness in
these matches he alluded to his match
and how Dynamic the play was how he went
for his chances is that what is missing
from Wesley right now it was Mel T who
said you want to take your opponent to a
deep dark Forest where 2 plus 2 equals 5
and there's only room out for just one
of you and that's what Fabiano said he
tried to do against Magnus whether
Fabiano was uncomfortable wasn't even
the most important thing it was making
Magnus uncomfortable Magnus was way too
comfortable in game one of set two there
he had an advantage from the early going
he opened the file controlled it so I
feel like Wesley will have to shake
things up how does Wesley so drag Magnus
into that deep dark Forest of
complications is the big task for Wesley
that's where his chances lie he has to
strike back he has to do it quickly but
David he starts with the black pieces
yeah I think first job in this next game
is survival it's a long day ahead Wesley
will need to strike back at some point
but he does have the prospect of
Armageddon if he just gets one more win
but he needs to stop uh stop the
bleeding right now he cannot let things
spiral this next game if he goes too
hard with black if he gets punished we
could see a very quick day so I think
this next one a draw is fine for Wesley
he just needs to play himself into form
but then he's got only one white left at
the end of this if he manages to
equalize things not get into too much
trouble and that ends in a draw I would
leave him with one white is that hedging
too much on that final white you just
want to give yourself some chances I'm
with you that the fewer games that
remain when you still have a deficit
against Magnus Carlson you're not a
happy camper but for Wesley if he loses
game two it's done if he draws game two
gets wi in game three even if he draws
that third game there still will be a
fourth and and then he can go all in I
think he should try to take this the
distance he should not commit too far
and lose the game two with the black
pieces from the start so Wesley I know
it's difficult for him but he needs to
be calm right now it's difficult for him
and you can see it in his face as well
right now as he walks in he's looking
shaky to me that confidence that belief
he needs to upt talk and find that in
him it's been a tough tough start for
Wesley so the big question how does he
manage to find that champion in himself
which he's done so many times the city
which he thrives in plays the best chess
in he has been playing phenomenally in
the round robin plays with the black
pieces twiddling there with the pieces
yeah and uh he has to do anything that
puts him in a good mood right now fiddle
with some pieces whatever it is listen
to some music he needs to get in the
zone Wesley so he's done it before he's
beaten Magnus several times in Rapid
chess Fisher random chess he's been in
that mindset before he's felt that
exhilaration but he needs to somehow
make sure it happens in these next three
games Wesley looking a bit nervous right
now walking from board to board finally
he takes his place he takes the seat
where he will be fighting to survive for
now he starts with the black pieces for
Magnus we saw his approach earlier where
needing only a draw he decided to play
one E4 inviting Wesley into his
preferred Berlin and forcing Wesley to
choose the Sicilian can we expect the
Kings Pawn opening from Magnus in this
one I definitely think that Magnus
should go for it because he had a stable
position the alipin Sicilian and here we
go we'll see if this comes true and
there's E4 best by test E4 best by test
and Wesley saw trying to create his
chances has to go for the Sicilian wow
Wesley so playing the Sicilian just as
he did yesterday Magnus goes for
something also offbeat here not an open
Sicilian not any Bishop B5 checks that I
would perhaps have predicted before the
day he puts the white Bishop on C4 so
this is uh going to a bit of an uh a bit
of a side there from Wesley so I was
going to say I was going to say uh it
kind of it's going to be a quiet
maneuvering battle not not just a side
but Wesley has frequently taken his
glasses off before the start of the game
he's got them on so I don't know if that
gives him some kind of extra Vision if
that will help him out here but Wesley
does seem bothered and how could he not
be he's trailing one set to none and now
in the second set he's also lost the
first game but this is just a position
at this stage he's not necessarily going
to find winning Chances with the black
pieces so if he could stabilize in this
one then go back to the drawing board
with the white pieces yeah and uh even
if he isn't able to get an advantage out
the opening with black get a attacking
position out the opening with black
first you just have to survive the early
stages and uh I think magnus's opening
here is pretty much designed to push the
tension into the middle game into the
later phases so Wesley should be happy I
think he should be thrilled with the the
outcome these last few moves Magnus
pausing as well right now of course it's
a level position white might be the
first to try and break out in the center
but Wesley's done nothing wrong he's got
a healthy uh development plan here
Black's going to Castle Black's Knight's
going to come out and Magnus gaining
space on the flanks it feels like Magnus
is playing against E5 as a first move
feels like he's set up in uh Italian
fashion but he's playing against the
Sicilian so there will be some added
twists a bit later on slow start to this
one Magnus keeps it in close Sicilian
territory but at some point we are
expecting a central break either from
white or from black seeing that deep
pawn move forward for Wesley right and
it does immediately so Wesley going for
D5 Magnus doesn't pause give gives a
check and before we Deep dive into this
analysis I want to ask you David how
much of a challenge is it for Wesley
right now to also leave behind what has
just happened in game one with the white
PES it's a challenge uh he wouldn't be
human if he didn't feel the effects feel
the the uh kind of aftermath of that
heartbreaking defeat in the previous
game with white and uh yeah I think
Wesley more than others wow moving his
King out of this check not even blocking
it definitely feels like that previous
game has got to him this might be a
decent decision uh there's nothing wrong
with it because the center's closed but
it does feel like Wesley more than
others would be uh kind of affected by
the psychology here and look at him he
does not look happy at all at the board
this is by far the lowest we've seen him
this week it was a good move that light
Square Bishop that just gave the check
is almost trapped if you gave Wesley the
turn that Bishop is going to be
eliminated so I think that Wesley made a
good practical decision in a game where
he wants to give himself some chances I
think he has chances now even if he's
looking dejected he should be focused
because Magnus has to figure out how to
save that piece this is heartbreaking to
see all week we've been seeing Wesley in
great spirits he's been joking he's been
bringing so much positive energy happy
and right now we're just seeing a
completely different Wesley so he's
broken from what has just happened in
game one or is this just mind games I'm
not sure but Wesley needs to get himself
together yeah he looks dejected on the
camera and uh the camera images the
board they do not match uh I kind of
agree with Robert here that uh he might
be lulling his opponent into a false
sense of security Wesley so because
actually on the board it's getting a bit
sharp now and that shoot should suit him
in a situation where he needs to strike
back he needs to win at some point today
a bit of a shake of the head though but
why it's still a tense position on the
board everything to play for all pieces
left White's Bishop will soon be trapped
if we can get the analysis board here
because this is a critical moment and
Wesley is continuing to shake his head
he's got multiple options here one of
which is to ignore the fact that his
Knight's under attack and counter
against the light score Bishop but he
can also bring his Knight back to the
starting point and how is that Bishop
escaping let's say you go Knight to G8
and white plays D4 let's free up a
diagonal for the bishop black plays C4
oh no you don't you're not getting out
of here now how do you save the bishop
you have to I think play the move Pawn
to A5 just to avoid this trap but after
A6 Bishop A4 Queen takes A5 I don't even
care and he's played Knight G8 so step
one it's a good decision you've stolen a
pawn now Magnus has to prove the
compensation we know the black king will
not be perfectly safe it lost the right
to Castle but you have the material and
this is the imbalance that you would
hope to have in a must-win type of game
this is a dream this is a fantasy for
any player in a must-win situation he's
a porn up uh and this is the most
logical line right now I think would be
forced to kick that black queen away and
then create some lift some Escape
squares for the white Bishop but yeah I
mean it's imbalanced the center is
blocked there's going to be no quick
draws here um you have extra material
what more could you want why is Wesley
show uh shaking his head right now it's
a mystery I love his choices here he's
about to trap this white bishop and
Magnus needs to react to that big threat
on his Bishop on B5 but even this final
line that you just showed the final
position that you showed it feels like
because of the lack of development that
we see on the board on the right side of
the board that even down upon Magnus
should have compensation but that's
exactly what Wesley is aiming for right
now an imbalanced position where he's up
material and his opponent Magnus Carlson
has to prove compensation and that word
compensation is often one we use when we
don't know how to prove that
compensation like oh we see that it's
even because there's compensation for
the sacrifice Pawn what does that mean
where is a George Carlin skit may he
rest in peace about compensation but it
is a word that we often use because
we're not exactly sure which side we'd
even prefer white will get some chances
because black lost the ability to Castle
that King has already moved and you see
Magnus he plays the move A5 and if I'm
Wesley here it comes A6 take that pawn
on A5 and then figure out the rest later
Magnus has more to prove than Wesley at
this stage a spicy opening and uh
exactly the kind of perhaps chest that
Fabby was earlier advocating for going
for it taking these chances and we're
going to see Magnus trying to prove that
compensation well well visually it's
clear that you've got to Target that
lack of development that King on the
file right now hoping for a central
close that D Pawn moving forward and
perhaps we can see Magnus trying to open
up that f file to try to line that Rook
against the king move the Knight step
away with that Knight get that F Pawn
moving up the board trying to create
chances for a king attack yeah Magnus
would love to open it hence his last
move the pawn pushing pushing forward to
C4 whether it's breaking open the file
as you indicate there Tanya whether it's
just exploding the center somehow if mag
opens things Black's lack of development
will come back to haunt Wesley so this
one's very much hanging in the balance
um your kind of your thoughts there
about compensation Robert reminds me of
all these old books I grew up reading
the unclear symbol this uh kind of
infinity symbol it was just left at the
end of any complicated variation like
this because authors don't know
commentators don't know it just looks
messy and uh there's no kind of uh
specific way to define this position in
one sentence we can say Black's up a
porn white is ahead in development but
it's still up to the players to prove it
and Wesley blocks the center even
further well that infinity symbol is
also one for forever and I'm forever
loving this kind of Chess on the board
where now we are definitely going to see
some uh Dynamics on the board the
imbalances here and I think this makes
it clear that Wesley is not hedging all
his hopes on that final white game he
wants to try to get a decisive one in
this one it's sort of magnus's fault
because the line he played is not
standard against the Sicilian as David
said earlier it's like he was playing
against the Kings Pawn opening trying to
get an Italian game where it doesn't
exist and right now he is down upon Pawn
that Bishop on A4 it looks like it's pin
it could have been one but that dark
Square Bishop for white can always slide
one square uh in on the diagonal to hit
the black queen so even just a turn ago
before Pawn to D4 was played B5 that's a
move that looks like it wins a piece
because that Bishop on A4 unfortunately
can't leave as The Rook on A1 is loose
behind it but Bishop to D2 will take
care of business forcing the queen out
there or the pawn push but that's
neither here nor there because Magnus
continues his development bringing his
Knight into the center that Knight may
go to B3 to kick the queen it may go up
to E4 and over towards the king side
that black king on f8 there aren't too
many white attackers in front of it so
it's not unsafe just yet but down the
line once the Knight jumps then the dark
SC Bishop gets involved and as T said
maybe even Pawn pushes later it does
seem like white can launch an attack but
for now I would say the status quo is
allowing black to retreat the queen
develop pieces and say I am a pawn to
the
continue to prove it Magnus let's see it
very often in these kind of Pawn
structures that we have the one that
black has created with the C5 D4 bind
we've been talking about the break from
the file you can also start targeting
the base of that pawn C5 breaks like B4
are always in the air and watch out for
them they might come at some point once
the queen does retreat white will have
the option to try to destabilize Wesley
in the center and we've seen these ideas
in the Boni in the banko from different
sides the reversed colors I would't be
surprised if the play shifts from the
King side to the queen side yeah and if
we look at the pawn structure Magnus has
the most advanced porn right now or one
of the most advanced porns in the center
it's basically cutting the board in half
so white here with the space Advantage
with the lead in peace development is
able to plant pieces in the center and
then switch Focus uh I completely agree
and yeah this King on f8 I really hate
it is really going to cause Wesley a lot
of trouble long term I think it's more
the attitude that we're impressed with
here in the studio the fact that he's
fighting and this is what Wesley needed
to show in the first game and uh what
we're loving right now yes White's
position objectively is probably better
yes White's position is probably more
fun to play because who cares about a
porn it's more about Black's King being
misplaced Black's pieces half asleep on
the backline but Wesley is fighting he's
been ambitious he's taken a pawn he's
going to try and hold on to it and
definitely going to uh put some burden
on Magnus a bit later he does need to
act energetically though Wesley so the
camera picture is slightly worrying on
that front and when you're head by
material we're often told to to trade
down and that could help in your
defensive task as well because with
fewer pieces remaining on the board
there are fewer attackers that white
will have and he plays Queen C7 I was
wondering about Bishop D7 as well just
developing while trying to trade off the
light score Bishops I I I see the B4
plan T mentions a really good idea
trying to undermine uh the black pawn
structure black can at some point take
on B4 giving up the center for some
queenside passers the imbalances will
continue and that's really all you can
hope for at this early stage only 12
moves into this game and Magnus how
could he be comfortable here it's a funl
looking position it's Dynamic play but
as Fabiano was advocating for you need
to put Magnus in uncomfortable territory
this isn't preparation this is all
inspiration and I think that for a
change it's Wesley who should be
inspired to look for his advantages here
he is up a pawn the E5 Pawn may be more
of a Target than an asset from the
Whit's perspective I like the play that
Wesley is showing he just needs to keep
pacing the clock and keep his confidence
High finally we are seeing some
ambitious chests by w Wesley so perhaps
something that he had to do earlier
perhaps something that he needed to
start the match with in set one itself
but now it is time for him to go for it
and that's what he does Bishops have
been offered to to be traded here Magnus
goes for the more solid approach of
developing pieces getting them at the
right spot before you think about any
break whether it's the F Pawn the B Pawn
or even eyeing that D6 Square that's a
nice juicy post for the Knight to land
on yes it will result in the trade of
the bishop and the Knight but if that E
Pawn gets to D6 that could be a really
powerful Pawn as well is Knight D6 an
idea that Magnus can work towards yeah
let's check it out Tanya let's uh try
and see whether Magnus can land a
monster Knight an octopus Knight on D6
and um I'm wondering whether you trade
off let's say we ignore it he he he
answers for us he does trade off let's
say we see a capture with the Black
Knight hitting this Pawn in the center
and now the white Bishop comes out if
black does nothing here I'm not sure how
black does nothing then the Knight can
land on D6 and just to show how strong
this Pawn would be uh in this Square I
think this would actually land white a
decent Advantage you open up the Rook
the White Knight might come in the White
Queen might follow on the diagonal still
unclear whether the Magnus should rush I
will uh admit but uh definitely on the
card so I think we'll see that first
move at least at least hinting that the
Knight might land on that outpost on the
board I think Wesley should push his H
Pawn I know you're not supposed to push
Pawns in front of your king when there
might be an attack but he needs to
develop his Knight out of G8 that Knight
was developed very early in the game
then had to step back to its initial
square but I would play H5 so that I
could play Knight H6 next you play
Knight D6 I don't have to take you right
away I think that's an important uh
instructive moment for many people at
home they think I need to take that
Knight it's going to threaten me but you
could start with Knight H6 there's
nowhere that Knight can go from D6 you
can take it on the next turn or in the
future so for Wesley he is holding on to
everything in both Direction it's
getting extremely complicated there's no
denying that but this is the territory
that Fabiano was saying you need to take
Magnus he's not always perfect he plays
with high accuracy was over 98% in those
four games yesterday people going crazy
on social media and they should because
that pinpoint precisions would earn
Magnus so many points but this is the
type of position that like Ali Raza fuja
the style he plays it's less accurate
I'm putting that in quote but it's
because he's taking his opponents into
this treacherous territory where it's so
difficult to find the accurate
continuations I think that Wesley he
needs to keep the pace as I've been
saying play H5 develop the Knight to H6
it's a messy game Just go with it and we
speak so much about styles of the top
players now one thing's clear to be the
best in the world to be in the top 10
you have to have a universal style you
can't have big gaping holes in one
territory of the game and be extremely
strong in the other you can't give
targets to to your opponent and these
players these top players they are
Universal in nature they're good in
every kind of positions but I think when
we speak about stylistic Chess we're
referring to instinctively and
intuitively the kind of decisions that
they take David and this kind of a
position that we have in front of us
intuitively who does it suit
more that one is hard to say I could I
think actually it suits uh both well I
was going to say it doesn't suit both
right now and uh I think that benefits
Wesley so um you talked about the deep
dark Forest this looks pretty murky to
me and uh also we have to remember in
2019 winning the world Fisher random
championship against Magnus Carlson that
was random that was kind of pieces all
over the board with weird uh kind of
non-typical patterns and that's where
Wesley so has his chances against Magnus
no matter the objective evaluation he's
achieved at least a mess on this board
and oh I saw him reach for the P Robert
he pushes it just one square either way
he's woken up and like you say Tanya yes
it's uh kind of the style that we like
to talk about players it's about the
Instinct it's about their preferences
but as long as he has enough time on the
clock he can maneuver this position he
can work with it it's given him a great
Foundation to fight um so I think as as
long as he stays uh at a decent time on
the clock this position still plenty of
chances as Magnus pushes his H point
forward as well well that caught me by
surprise a little bit I thought he would
push that one square like Wesley just
did instead instead of two but he's
taking away Wesley's immediate threat
though that pawn H4 it does stick out
it's in front of your king it can become
a Target Magnus he looks like he is
enjoying this position it's one where
you really need to dig deep and
calculate and he's aead on the clock
that's actually I think maybe the most
important aspect of this position you
see the evaluation bar off the side
saying white maybe slightly better A lot
of you saying well isn't there a pawn
missing from this position both players
they don't have that assessment that
they're working with their own internal
assessment functions and they know it's
unclear that's that is obvious but now
where does Wesley go his King side is
not developed he needs to get those
pieces out yeah he's got an extra Pawn
but he's playing with that The Rook on
h8 without the Rook on A8 and for now
even without the Knight on G8 Wesley
needs to find the time and move moves to
actually develop these pieces to make
something of that extra pawn and yes
it's exactly the kind of position that
you're looking for given the math
situation but if we keep that aside
objectively here to me it does look like
white should have enough play with plans
of sunlight jumping to D6 with plans of
the B Pawn moving forward undermining
the center as we have it I would pick
white here David what about you Robert
if you had to pick a color here would
you go for material or compensation in
this one I think until this last move I
might have taken black just because I
like my material yes White's a pawn
being absent isn't relevant right now
probably won't be relevant till the end
game this material balance but I thought
black had stability I don't like
Wesley's last move it's taken that
square that you wanted uh away from that
Black Knight on G8 it feels like this
has helped Magnus this little inclusion
of porn pushes Magnus has gained space
now I might take white but uh yeah I
mean that's how fickle top chess players
can be uh if you ask the players maybe
they would say the same it's unclear I
think again I I still love what Wesley's
been doing in terms of attitude but it
does feel like uh it doesn't suit his
kind of mindset for the tournament right
now and I'm trying to figure out what
his plan was because H4 does stop his
immediate threat which is to push the G
pawn and he goes one square with it so
he is taking this very cautiously it's a
ginger like approach is just moving
slowly trying to make things work on the
king side and meanwhile the idea that
Tanya was advocating for a long time ago
Pawn to B4 has been played so I don't
like the way that Wes's handled the last
few moves maybe he can actually take
this Pawn in before I know he drops a
Central Pawn in return but things remain
messy although I am starting to like
magnus' chances because of Wesley's last
two moves yeah and magnus's practical
skills are so so strong Wesley spent an
age deciding to push a little Pawn on
the king side Magnus instantly reacts by
throwing a pawn forward on the queen
side he was thinking in his opponent's
time first of all then he was ready to
pounce on his opponent's vulnerability
and look at those white pieces in the
middle of the board centralization over
everything and looking very very strong
for white right now and there's just so
much to learn because when I bought up
the idea of B before right a couple of
moves ago that's what maybe many of us
would do instantly but Magnus first gets
all his pieces at the right position he
develops everything gets everything
centralized and only then strikes in the
center and that's just what I see these
top Grand Masters always do they wait
with the threat until the right moment
yeah they build up they strike when they
sense their opponents aren't quite ready
and Magnus he played two three moves in
a flurry there now he'll pause again and
he still has to find a plan of attack
against the black king but even if he
were to take a slow approach even if
White's Knight now on the dile that just
captured a pawn drops back throw those
white Pawns in the center up the board
black is frozen we've talked about it
before um I was trying to avoid
objective kind of assumptions here like
white being better black being better
because I loved what Wesley was doing
taking risks but now the dust is
starting to clear starting to settle and
Black's pie is just not ready for the
fight and white does need to keep an eye
on that H4 Pawn look at Magnus he's
creating a direct threat that Queen is
in line with the black king I think
Wesley pushed his Pawn one square to G6
so it's king and there it goes it runs
out of the way we should show that a
moment ago ideas of Knight takes Pawn on
E6 were really threatening Bishop takes
H6 check Knight takes E6 to follow
because the F7 Pawn was pinned so Wesley
he is scrambling out of the center on
the board that's the good news and he
still has a plan he could push that H
Pawn get his Knight out to H6 so Magnus
does have work to do here this isn't
just like oh suddenly we love his
position it's game over and he hops that
Knight into D6 which I think we all were
saying was a good idea if you take on D6
it's replaced by Pawn but maybe he
should take it and brings Queen out to
C5 E6 to E5 becomes a threat in these
positions the Knight now can go out to
F6 instead of sitting at home on G8 so
at least for Wesley there are some plans
for him in this position as compared to
before where he was completely Frozen
yeah I actually think he'll be loving
play this little transition as black
Wesley so I'm expecting him to use the
C5 Square as well for the black queen
but it's just the fact that at least now
he has something clear to do earlier it
was very kind of uh yeah it was very
unclear to say the least about where
black species should go but this night
coming out will be a lifesaver and wow
he drops back with the black queen
instead that feels a bit odd somehow
feels counterintuitive the black Queen's
so passive but still he's getting
developed that black knight coming out
Magnus needs to strike here and now
still upon on down yeah but he could
have gotten developed with Tempo put
pressure on White's pieces attack that
Knight on D4 keep your queen connected
to that D6 Pawn I loved your idea of
Queen to C5 the more active approach in
this position which would be the logical
followup to what Wesley has been doing
with his play so far once again to me
this just reflects Wesley's cautious
overly cautious play I think part of it
though is um done because of the time
I'm looking at Wesley's clock he only
has 4 minutes remaining that B7 Pawn was
a bit loose so maybe he's just saying
I'm going to going to defend everything
and perhaps he believes in the
foundation of his position because he is
going to play Knight F6 next his Rooks
will be connected and that pawn on D6
which really is a thorn in Black side in
fact it forced the queen backwards
that's something that you have to keep
an eye on maybe Magnus will have to drop
that later in the game if he can't keep
it under control and the last thing I'll
say is that that Bishop on F4 if that
were on B2 oh this could be game over so
I'm already actually thinking of
rerouting that Bishop back to C1
retreating moves often the hardest to
play in chess as a commentator I always
have to say look what your pieces are
look where they'd be best placed a dream
move could be a killer move and a bishop
getting back on over there at some point
maybe even now could really hurt Wesley
that's a really nice plan that you're
pointing out Robert about rewriting that
Bishop from F4 to the killer diagonal
the sniper that would be on that B2
square and perhaps that's something on
magnus's agenda right now we speak about
Alpha zero all the time we speak about
how Magnus channels his own Alpha zero
and that H4 do you want to include with
H5 in this position do you want to fix
that pawn on H5 or do you think this is
the better Pawn structure for white I
think this is a fine Pawn structure for
white I think keep that up your sleeve
for later um it's always going to be in
the air Pawn to H5 for white trying to
break open the black king why Rush when
uh it might become stronger later when
things have cleared up a bit uh I'm
loving the white Bishop stepping back
whites of Rooks at some point need to
join the uh join the fun but Magnus in
the tank now for 2 minutes again it's
that murky type of position which
nobody's comfortable in Fabiano said it
himself Fabby in those games against
Magnus he won three of them he wasn't
comfortable but nor was Magnus and that
is already step one and you can see
Magnus not entirely sure what he should
be doing next it looks nice pretty for
white but you're still up on down that's
in the back of your mind match situation
in the back of your mind and anything
could still happen here and those are
exactly the kind of positions we saw in
the AI cup where Maxim booked his ticket
to Toronto he took down Magnus not in
one set but in two sets in the finals
and it was exactly these kind of chaotic
positions where both players have
chances opportunity to go completely
wrong a mess on the board and Maxim was
on top of that and it feels like Fabby
took a leaf out of the maxim book and
created his chances and won three games
against Magnus in these positions so
Wesley's managed to achieve it but the
one thing that is a little different
from those other two storylines is the
clock situation because Fabby and Maxim
also did keep pressure on the clock and
right now I see Wesley failing to do
that but Magnus is in for a three plus
minute think at this stage you are right
that Wesley's been trailing on the clock
but right here right now if Magnus
continues to be perplexed by the
position because it's super complicated
then Wesley can say all right I'm not
getting checkmated I'm still a pawn
ahead and look at those queenside pass
pawns that Wesley has he has three pawns
on the A and B files and that pawn on B4
that one could be an annoying passer and
that pawn on D6 the most advanced white
Pawn as we've been talking about that
that can actually be scooped up at some
point if Magnus isn't careful Magnus
he's down below 3 minutes 45 seconds he
spent nearly 4 minutes on this turn
David he's not happy about some of these
developments yeah he's Frozen somehow
Magnus Carlson he spent more than his
half of his remaining time on this one
move and I did also notice Wesley
shaking his head kind of put his head on
his hand feels like Wesley's playing
mind games bluffing Magnus here trying
to distract Magnus somehow but yeah the
Norwegian here the world number one he
has to move has to move fast this little
chain now the fact that black has a
clear next couple of moves Black's night
coming out that's pretty much a pre
movable uh choice on the next turn
things could turn Wesley should be happy
should be thrilled with how things are
going and we know we've been building up
to this moment in this game right where
there are so many further critical
decisions to be taken and those extra
seconds will really count on the clock
the position is just starting to get uh
complicated right now and we see Wesley
there his body language if that's a
Bluff that's some great acting that I've
just witnessed today I mean it's just
look at him why is he shaking his head I
mean it's exactly the dream position
that he wants right he's shaking his
head because we're talking about it and
Magnus must be paying attention to it as
well I mean psychology plays such a huge
role in each individual chess game
Magnus has spoken about this at length
and now Magnus has made his move he
slides his Rook over and that evaluation
bar has slid down right towards the
middle this position is not easy for
either side even if the engine may say
oh it's fine for black the position
could collapse any moment but Wesley he
can develop that Knight out to F6 and
complete his development at long last
there we go relatively quick there he
could have played it instantly though
Wesley so and magnus's plan is revealed
he slides his Knight back getting ready
to potentially Propel white Central
pawns forward and okay black still a
pawn up activate that black rook in the
corner or push maybe you can even push
the black pawns now and he's fine he's
healthy uh his position here Wesley so
he needs to keep putting Magnus under
pressure on that clock I love the idea
of Pawn to B6 because your A6 Pawn is
defended by the queen then push A5 and
you create a pawn chain it's not the
most natural looking Pawn chain with the
double pawns there but it's very strong
he first centralizes Rook can hardly
blame him for that but at some point
those B Anda pawns can be a huge
distraction to White's pieces so Magnus
will not be able to go all in for the
attack but do has gave Magnus enough
time to reroute that dark Squad Bishop
that we're talking about either fall
back one step or all the way to C1 and
try and get it on that deadly diagonal
once that Bishop drives on the A1 h8 it
could be big trouble for black in the
position and we also see Magnus now
touching the two-minute Mark is he
getting a bit shaky Magnus isn't feeling
too comfortable that's obvious from his
clock use here uh the fact that he's
blown his time advantage and is now down
under two minutes Magnus Carson he's
also still down upon porn and uh I keep
repeating it but the longer that goes on
the more doubt will be in his mind um
I'm liking some of those Bishop
Maneuvers maybe Magnus can also try and
push some of his Central Pawns in the
next few moves but either way it's not
an easy position to maneuver to navigate
this one no instinctive moves he's
reaching Bishop all the way back goes
back to C1 so he's found a better
diagonal for it he remains down a pawn
if he had slid to D2 rather than C1 he
probably could have scooped up the B4
Pawn but Wesley would be able to strike
in the center and speaking of strike in
the center there goes Wesley's E Pawn
that D6 Pawn that passer for white it
could be in some trouble as black is
about to surround it okay and Wesley
there just adjusting a piece I did see
him say Jad he did touch his Rook Magnus
not calling him out on that one but the
white Bishop has landed it's on the same
diagonal as the black king Wesley now
goes for that alternate plan that we
mentioned he's combining all these ideas
if black gets two more moves if black
gets to play Pawn to A5 and for example
offer a queen trade put the queen in the
corner suddenly Wesley could well be
better Magnus needs to blow open the
middle of the board Unleash the Power of
that Bishop before it's too late but one
minute against three this is high stakes
Wesley needs to strike this game he
needs to take it I feel for the
tournament this is the big opportunity
that we have been waiting for for Wesley
so to have and now it all comes down to
will he make the most of it or not will
he be able to finish this job off
because just hedging it on that last
white game will not be enough against
the world number one it's a mess
anything can happen a game for all three
results and we see now Magnus down to
under a minute he's going for the
kingside attack both players just going
for it at this moment and the evaluation
bar is dipping in Black's favor all of a
sudden because Magnus is going for the
attack against the black king that white
king is losing some of its shelter and
if that Knight on D7 could move out the
way suddenly the white uh the white Pawn
on G4 is in the sight of black sing wo I
love that move King G8 getting out of
that Bishop's long range I think that
was the best move on the board and a
really great choice in magnus's time
travel yeah g for Glory Magnus going for
it by pushing his Pawn forward but also
G for gaping because there are gaping
holes around the white King right now
this could really backfire on Magnus
cars and he starts retreating his pieces
uh the White Knight coming back now also
a move that I quite like because White's
Knight will most likely install itself
back in the center of the board soon but
Wesley again keep that pace going he's
found his rhythm now the last three four
moves have come within 10 15 seconds he
needs to keep that pressure on there we
go again improving his Rook what could
be more natural really strong play by uh
Wesley right now defending the Knight
another time hitting the pawn in the
center Magnus said a now he says b or
should we say says G G5 attacking the
Knight trying to open up the black King
and wesle here he can take this Pawn on
G5 I'd be a little bit nervous on
opening up the H file for a future check
minting attack I wonder if he can just
slide his Knight back to E8 because he
may give up H6 and gain the D6 pawn and
if that pawn Falls the Knight is able to
maneuver itself back to the F5 Square
for example I think we're talking about
an advantage for Wesley so and now that
I see the evaluation bar as well saying
black is indeed better here objectively
yeah he's just mulling over whether to
trade off he does trade off these set of
Pawns H file is open so Black's King
White's King both of them feeling a bit
nervous about this little transformation
and he actually goes back the other way
a bit of a passive Square I liked your
idea Robert scoop off that far Advanced
White pawn and anyone's game there but
uh now Magnus if he lands the White
Knight back into the center then I think
he's going to get that piece traded off
Wesley he's got everything covered
Magnus keeps the tension the White Queen
sliding slowly towards that open H line
wow both kings are sweating right now
that's a sneaky move because you're not
only defending G5 but you're eyeing to
go to H4 to try set up a mating attack
Wesley grabs the pawn Magnus strikes in
the center it is all about opening up
that Bishop on B2 to get it to attack
the black king black has to make a big
decision right now with that D4 Pawn you
really do not want to open up the
diagonal and The Rook on D6 is spinned
so watch out you can't pick up that pawn
on D4 with your own Pawn but you can
with the rook and that's what I would go
for because if you get rid of White's
best piece I know Rooks are more
valuable than Bishops Five Points three
points but you get a pawn as well so you
actually get four points uh for black
and then white takes that Rook for five
he goes for it Wesley so is feeling the
position and we can see a complete shift
in Wesley so's body language as well
he's not only feeling good about the
position but he's suddenly looking
confident as well he gives up that Rook
for that Bishop taking away a key
attacking piece in White's position and
meanwhile those Queens side pawns are
going to start going up the board Magnus
makes a move and the evalar drops the
evalar drops Wesley's actually aead of
material he's given up rook for pieace
but look at this his Knight comes in now
he's got four versus one in terms of
Pawns on the queen side flank and uh
maybe Wesley missed something bigger
there something stronger maybe Black's
Queen could have activated but either
way if he stabilizes if he avoids
getting checkmated Wesley so long term
Black's pawns are Marching black is
winning so these next few moves are
critical they're essential 20 seconds
for Magnus Carson Wesley now under one
minute but Nock said when he was playing
against Wesley in semi-finals and Wesley
was shaking in time trouble he's
defending his F7 Pawn preempting any
attack but the Vantage excuse me is
going up for white right now it's
because black is on the defensive I
think that Queen from C8 has to LEAP out
to F5 start posing some problems towards
the white king side but white has two
Rooks and black only has one a mistake
from Wesley he's pushing pawns but he's
ignoring the flank where the action is
really happening it's all on the king
side where the Kings stand right now
minus slice his King up watch out for
White's Rook to slide behind White's
Queen the open H line there's going to
be checkmating Patton's Galore over
there Wesley he has to activate his
Queen before it's too late yeah either
can the cck are com in with the queen
attacking the G5 Pawn but don't keep
that Queen just there you need to act
right now against the threat of Rook to
H1 that would be game over Wesley has to
make a big move right now he is about to
play he's under 30 seconds I'm expecting
something with the queen right now
either give a check or the move Robert
you were advocating for I think the
check loses I think that if you check
from the corner white pushes the pawn
and blocks the dle and then Rook H1 is
Unstoppable pre movable so he might have
to play Queen F5 he does that to ract by
white now Queen D7 I think is the only
choice so that when white doubles up on
the H file you push your F Pawn and
defend on the seventh rank he finds the
best defense again Wesley so two moves
in a row he found the only move Magnus
slides his Rook across you can see both
players so nervous right now Magnus
testing the opponent setting trap
setting threats Wesley dodging again
defending well he's holding on here
Wesley so and Rook H1 is about to land
it will be the seventh rank defense from
the queen with the F Pawn moving forward
Wesley immediately blitzes out mag
making moves with just 3 seconds on the
clock the Knight jumps into the attack
now offering a trade if it's taken the G
Pawn is weak Wesley panics he takes a
Pawn off the board and now lands his
Knight in but he's giving up his own
Black Knight and White's Knight jumps in
with a fork dropping F2 F2 is falling
The Rook can use an intermetal taking F2
with check and then take the white Rook
will Wesley see it oh he misses it
Wesley so could have picked up the F2
Pawn with a check wow we getting moves
on the board but Wesley could have won
he still has a pawn though he's about to
promote and those black pawns are
running our Bard is Frozen Let's watch
the Players right now those black pawns
against the might of White's Rook Wesley
grabs a piece to fiddle with it's a race
I don't think the white r can stop them
cuz there there a second Pawn he could
push the a pawn his Knight is not under
attack and by the way the black king was
threatening the White Knight there the
pawn they're Unstoppable Wesley's
winning again Magnus has panicked
there's nothing Magnus can do this is a
check black just moves and those black
pawns it's all about the pawns new
Queens incoming for black that Aon moves
one step forward and it is game over
Wesley will for now move forward with
his King find a way to avoid the checks
Magnus can just give checks but the king
moves towards the center of the board oh
watch out for Rook D7 he wants to make
this I don't know what it's called a
windmill back and forth he's a check he
found it and he he covers the square
Wesley so wins the game what a comeback
Magnus cson resigns and you can see it
he was so close to taking this one what
a game wesle so stays in the fight
getting a win with the black pieces in a
dramatic finish wow it was a deep dark
forest and only Wesley so emerged
unscathed there we saw him bang the
table in frustration before finding the
winning move the emotions are running
high but he's struck back there is so
much on the line in this match
$200,000 goes to the winner 100,000 for
the player that ends in second we see
Wesley he looks at that poster that
displayed every move matters and Wesley
found the best moves when it mattered
most and every game matters right now
and the players are just finding out
when the next game starts try and listen
in and Magnus you can see he's angry so
that's why I was ping for it but if not
then 15 15 is good okay let's try to
push 15 that's wow and Magnus and wessy
so leave the playing arena in just a few
minutes they will be back to fight for
game three and Wesley is back in the
match with a win with the black pieces
in absolutely chaotic position it was a
roller coaster and just when everybody
maybe including Wesley so was writing
him off he finds it within himself to
score a win to deliver a punch to Magnus
Carlson who looked indomitable thus far
but he suffers his first loss here in
the title match Magnus Carlson a big big
wakeup call for him that one at the end
again it was all about the complications
and Wesley managed to create them with
the black pieces and come out on top of
it one of the most chaotic games one of
the most unruly games I've ever seen and
in the end it was Wesley Who tricked
Magnus Carlson when the tactic started
and it was here that that Madness began
white actually has a promising position
White's attack on the H file looks
extremely promising but Wesley threw a
span it in the works not the best move
but a tricky move and one that confused
Magnus Carson he brought his Knight into
D3 threatening now some uh some ideas
against the F2 Pawn threatening to come
back with a check Magnus threw his
Knight in with a fork and it was here
that the world number one blundered he
should simply have taken this black Rook
with an advantage for white instead he
traded off the Queens he forced the
Queens off the board by capturing this
Knight but suddenly Wesley was winning
Rook takes porn is even stronger but
what he played was good enough he took
this Rook off the board and suddenly you
see white is a rook up what could go
wrong it's all about these black pawns
though these black pawns are running
they're pushing and just to show a quick
action replay of the end stages of this
game it's all about these pawns running
down the board there's two of them and
the white Rook is helpless nothing to do
here but there was one final trick we
saw Wesley smash his hand down on the
board thinking he'd blown it it was here
in this position and after the king slid
across Rook to D7 suddenly white is
threatening to draw if black promotes to
a new Queen it is a draw on the spot No
Escape from these checks it's checks for
eternity but Wesley found the winning
move a bit bit of frustration but he
found it in the end a KN check the
Knight drops back to H5 suddenly the F6
square is covered and no more Perpetual
check these pawns incoming two Queens
Landing Wesley won there's no power
quite like willpower and I think that
Wesley he really dug deep there he
believed in himself and he earned that
Victory he stole a pawn even though he
was shaking his head but he's the one
who's making magnus's head shake he's
probably enraged because Wesley so all
of a sudden when he the black pieces
evens it up it's 1 it's anybody set to
at the stage just when we were all ready
to write this off uh Wesley so strikes
back and Toronto had a reaction take a
look at what
happened
wow big round of applause coming in for
Westley so with that finish and it
deserved it finding that critical last
move till the very end Wesley staying
Vigilant and getting the win in every
move matters Robert as you said we we
saw it on the displayed and you can get
your hands on that displayed as we've
got a cool 33% off use the code chess
and there is more more exciting chess
coming
up Toronto is where the action's
happening and we will be back with the
game three and a breakdown from the gang
in Toronto they are having a lot of fun
and we will have a lot of fun when we
return from this uh shot
[Music]
break
[Applause]
[Music]
a
oh
m
for
okay
oh my God these are Big Russian
[Music]
words Sherlock
[Laughter]
Holmes
internet
[Music]
you
joh you just gave a shout out to the
displate discount I'm going to give a
shout out to the displates on the wall
here right to our left they are sexy you
can go to displate.com chest you know
the drill but seriously you should they
are pretty awesome like not kidding like
they're so easy to throw up and they're
actually they feel really cool and
obviously there'll be many more many
more designs appreciate displate and uh
I expect a lot of fans to take advantage
of those I expect a lot of fans to be
losing their minds right now guys
because just when we were all thinking y
this could be this could be a three-
game day out of here Wesley so says not
so fast yeah that was basically a a much
needed wakeup call and it was something
he he probably couldn't generate himself
I mean he played the right opening but
it was really Magnus who created a
complicated position Wesley lost the
right to Castle it was super imbalanced
despite being a pawn up Wesley had the
negative evaluation according to the
computer Rook sacrific for defensive
measures and attack down the H file
nervous decisions with 10 seconds on the
clock these guys looked human for the
first time in the entire event oh my God
I was on the edge of my seat yeah if I'm
Wesley you know we even saw it in his
face he was like oh you know he just
shaking his head after King f8 and then
he leave like ah dny let's go go Beat Me
Up Ja they caught that on that that was
like if a fighter tasted their own blood
for the first time like W's the went oh
yeah okay I mean that was it literally
was it was like something woke him up
yeah and we got action here we got drama
who knows will we have tie breaks and
Armageddon yet again I don't know but I
do know that Kaa caught up with so after
that literally must-win
game what a massive comeback by Wesley
so and I first want to know Wesley how
are you doing right now what's happening
inside of
you uh well it's not been not not been a
good day okay not really in a good mood
the moment even after that
game well such an ugly game yeah like I
probably made probably made like six
blenders or something yeah so you win it
that must mean something yeah yeah for
sure wasn't especially proud of how I
won but it's very nice to to get a
victory against Magnus I thought I would
never making this but in the end I was
just you know I learned from him he said
to hustle so I was just hustling him in
the end kind kind of feel like coffee
house chess uh but uh it worked we
probably made like six blenders so I
mean the quality of the game was just
awful even the opening
like I think just grabbing this spawn
was a very stupid idea like all this
King f8
business so like I think A4 is still
Theory so I mean I should just castle
and and then enjoy an equal game but I
thought I grabb this
Pawn but then uh White just got really
good compensation for it like I would
not recommend this Pawn grab with King
f8 to and N G8 to to anyone again and I
would never play it uh and then then was
just uh crazy like he started using a
lot of time and that gave me a lot of
hope so If he if he manage his time
better like I think at one move he
thought for 4 minutes or something if he
didn't do that then he would have uh but
it's very he it's very nice to to get
the victory I I think I just uh put too
much pressure on myself I should just
play then if I lose I lose you know I
lost him yeah you've got nothing to lose
basically you have to win this match and
you're equal now you're tied so what is
it about now for you to be able to win
this match and take it to a set
three
I think just going for the Armageddon
might be a decent idea so I don't like I
already lost two white two games with
white and it's just
inexcusable but uh yeah I really hope to
put up a good fight a good a good show
today not personally for myself but uh
for the people watching you know really
appreciate them so shout out to them we
appreciate you Wesley congrats on that
massive win good luck in the next one
yeah I really thank you wow huge
comeback Wesley's always ready ready for
game three back to you
guys well he is putting up a huge fight
and the fans do appreciate it but I
don't even think he realizes he won he
won it's game on right we want to see
The Confident Wesley sell yeah I I all
I'll say is clearly when the pressure is
really really high and the moves have to
be made and the clock is ticking there's
a beast inside yeah and that's that's
who came out the clut defensive moves
sacrificing The Rook toward the end to
get the two pass pawns and then
ultimately he actually almost blew it
like Magnus almost found a configuration
at the end there I don't know if that
was really analyzed in great detail but
Wesley thought he had messed it up until
he found a night check to deflect
magnus's Knight away from the drawing
sequence that that was almost missed
there in all of the chaos so there is a
beast inside when it comes to making
moves he just doesn't go to the
interview and say yeah I'm the man I
woke up like I'm looking forward to game
three but I'm going to swing on him we
need another game or two like that from
Wesley to make the comeback 100% yeah
you can tell some confidence is back
there in interview right he's feeling a
little bit better so hopefully he's able
to take it to him in this third and
fourth game well that Beast inside will
now have the black pieces as we get set
to the back half of this match will we
have tiebreakers what are we in store
now that the goat Magnus Carlson takes
the first move and is he angry how
feisty will he be we're going to find
out but right now it's time for us to
throw right back to Oslo who's going to
have the call take it away all the big
questions you just asked Danny and we
will find the answers to them really
soon as game three is about to get
underway but that game two was one of
the most thrilling games of Chess I have
ever witnessed and Wesley called it
Coffee House chess style but it worked
in the end is this exactly the nudge
that he needed to switch up his style I
think so he still sounds a bit deflated
because he doesn't like losing with the
white pieces but Wesley you've already
given everybody a show beating Magnus
Carlson with the black pieces like that
the scramble that we saw at the end it
looked like black was blundering but he
had it all figured out because his pass
pawns were rolling and Wesley he's put
on a show it's 1-1 still life left
Coffee House chess the top players might
frown upon it but everyone else loves it
we love the pieces flying we love the
sudden swings in evaluation the twists
the turns the tactics pawns flying down
the board ultimately Wesley needs to be
inspired he needs to keep exactly that
magic that he uh kind of found in that
last few moves in this next game he has
white he lost with white in the previous
one Magnus doesn't look too thrilled
these days either this next game is
crial two big takeaways from game two
make the most of the opportunities and
don't trust Wesley's body language we
see him he's back on the board again
looking not as confident as we'd expect
after that game Victory he starts it is
one D4 the Queen's Pawn Magnus taking a
pause now thinking how he wants to
approach this David you know Magnus best
how is he how does he react mentally
after a loss like that normally Magnus
gets woken up we heard about the Beast
inside Wesley Magnus really bounces back
better than anyone El I think in chess
history from a defeat that being said he
is facing uh Wesley now awoken Wesley
and Magnus has the black pieces we see
the nimso Indian defense one of the most
solid classical openings in chess and
Wesley choosing a branch where he gets
the bishop pair early on so he has
something to hold on to long term it's
definitely pressure on Magnus to
equalize Magnus here he's set up in the
most solid way possible and we'll see
how that unfolds I'm wondering if he'll
strike with C5 because if Magnus is
feeling ambitious he can get into some
of these tactical positions where
there's deep Theory and I think you
don't see this at the highest level very
often uh but after a loss like that for
Magnus Carlson why should he take
unnecessary risk if he draws this game
he heads into the fourth game with the
white pieces the first move advantage
and he instead put brings Knight into E4
and only then plays C5 so these lines
they're well studied and Wesley he got
his hand on his jaw a little bit how
ambitious will he be that's my question
because we've learned that he's not even
happy with this play after beating
Magnus Carlson he's got reasons to be
happy about the result of that game but
he also mentioned in the interview that
he would be okay taking this to the
Armageddon now that was a strategy for
set one as well and it didn't work well
this approach of the opening we see
moves are being blitzed out we're still
in opening territory a big threat on F2
now stopped by Wesley so pieces are
being traded uh David what do you think
is this a game where Wesley is sticking
to what he said in the interview or will
he try for an edge with white it feels
like he's trying to be super solid here
this variation this branch of the nimzo
Indian has a notorious drawish tendency
white has a small symbolic Advantage uh
because White's Bishop is better than
the black Bishop White's Knight has more
potential than the Black Knight
ultimately though it is a symmetrical
Pawn structure and nothing too drastic
can go wrong here for black so yeah
looks like both players just happy to
play solid mirroring each other's
posture here the body language just
neither looking to energetic but I would
take white every day I think Wesley he's
just trying to take the sting out of the
position and he's hoping that Magnus is
a bit flustered from that last game that
being said no Deep Dark Forest here and
Magnus avoided the only opening trap
that I know of in this position so if we
can analyze and take it back a few moves
there's one little thing that Magnus
need to avoid and it's why we encourage
people to get their King safe and castle
and right now simple moves are playing
putting a rook on an open line um and
now for Magnus he doesn't have any
concerns there are no tactics available
to Wesley but if we can just back it up
a few moves here we saw that in if he
instead of castling said I'm going to
force everything off playing Knight to
E5 it looks like the bishop should move
and then the Queens are traded and we
just get an equal position but instead
of moving the bishop Knight E4 is a
clever move because if you take the
bishop now Knight D6 check happens so
I'm actually defending my bishop
tactically and if instead of taking the
bishop right away you make a move like
Queen C6 trying to keep the Queens on
the board in comes Bishop B5 and you
take my Bishop on B5 I get in Knight D6
check with another Fork winning the
queen so casting at that moment was very
precise and it's these little moments in
Chess at the high level where you have
to play the correct continuation because
if you give Wesley that chance he would
have been able to strike in the center
instead we see just equality both
players playing for the C and D files
and I think Wesley he's showing that
he's happy to just be equal make a draw
and try to stabilize the black the next
game yeah if Magnus can just deal with
the problem of this bishop this stuck
Bishop uh kind of just staring at its
own Pawn then Magnus is totally fine no
weaknesses at all in the black position
I'm expecting him maybe even to park the
bishop on a safe square like e just get
it out the way trade off with the Queens
Rooks uh as many pieces as possible and
live to fight another day he's reaching
for that piece that was the only uh
deficiency in his position he'll bring
the Rook now to C8 and I think he's
close to equality this one Wesley's last
white in regulation time could be
fizzling out unless he finds something
special in the next few moves well he is
putting pressure on the queen and now
the decision will be on Magnus will he
offer the trade that you were advocating
earlier with that F5 Square immediately
trying to get into an end game or does
he move back with the queen to E7 he
does decide to keep the Queens on the
board for now so looking at lining up
the Queens side Rook on the sea line
against White Queen which has just Sid
stepped any threats along the sea file
Magnus goes for the plan as you said
trying to double up on the defile get
the Rooks into play symmetrical Pawn
structure but this B on the queen side
the A3 B4 pawns does that give is this
as we like to say more equal for white
than black the Optics are good for
Wesley and that's not just because he's
got his glasses on and he keeping them
on but he has already control of the SE
file his pawns are more advanced he can
kick the enemy Knight away if he pushes
the B Pawn even further his Knight on D2
it's got room for improvement it can go
up to E4 and then over to C5 but you
can't actually pile up pressure on the
pieces so it is better for white you're
kind of playing for two results here but
if Magnus continues the way he's been
playing and is able to trade some pieces
he will have no problems whatsoever but
that's why Wesley he brought his Bishop
back to E2 he's going to reroute that
Bishop to F3 at the correct moment his
Queen on B2 is well placed a slight Edge
to Wesley so I think that uh he can play
safely for an advantage and if Magnus
plays perfectly we've seen the accuracy
levels being high here a draw is the
likely outcome between two of the best
players in the world yeah we talked
about stylistically who did the previous
game favor we unsure it was just too
messy uh neither player too comfortable
but this is well within both players
Comfort zones in this one Magnus he's
fine in these positional battles you can
trust his body language I think right
now because he feels like uh he's kind
of evaded the worst yes maybe one or two
small questions to answer but he should
ultimately be okay with black and uh
Wesley meanwhile this is right up his
alley minimal risk no sting in the
position and he can massage this
Advantage he can try to make use of that
extra space uh that's been initiated
with those Pawn push PES on the queen
side White's got the better minor pieces
long term but look at the Rooks
indirectly now they're almost staring at
each other and it's likely those pieces
will get traded off if those all
disappear it's really hard to imagine uh
the winning chances for white you can
see as well the speed with which they've
been playing now pretty far into the
middle game they're both much more
confident than in the previous crazy
battle also getting those nerves to
settle down after what just happened in
game two absolute chaos and the more we
see the more games of Magnus call that
that one would study you understand that
it's almost impossible to outclass
Magnus strategically in these slow
fights slow grinds even from equal
position he's the one who almost
invariably comes out on top so if you
really wanton those winning chances you
have to somehow drag him into those
forests of complications into those
chaotic messes that we saw in game two
earlier and uh right now it looks like
that's not going to be the narrative in
this one there are ideas of that knight
from D2 jumping forward to C4 the B Pawn
perhaps moving forward to B5 that Bishop
from E2 landing on F3 a nicer
diagonal and with black if Magnus does
equalize this completely and this does
go into a draw I think he's got reasons
to be happy despite losing game two with
white he starts game four with white and
and it's not going to stop him from
making his chances in that one playing
the odds getting the white pieces in a
one game remaining in regulation of
course Magnus will be happy about that
but he's I don't think happy about his
play overall we know from Magnus we've
heard from him over the years when he
loses a game especially when he feels
like he's not playing at his best that's
when he's most Disturbed and for Wesley
so calm game here and I just want to
note that it's easy to forget that these
players and particular Wesley have
played a ton of Chess in recent days
this is the eighth and final day here at
the Champions chess tour in terms of
just rated you know 15 minutes base time
for each player Wesley play 30 of those
games and that doesn't include
Armageddon so they're probably exhausted
at this stage we're in the eighth and
final day no days off for these players
they had an easier day uh on the fourth
day when some people were playing the
survival stage but then they're right
back to it into the semi-finals and it's
exhausting it really is exhausting
playing this high level chess and we'll
see who has enough left in the tank and
interestingly it was these two players
who managed to get a bit of time off in
that final round robin stage because
they did finish at the top of uh the
leaderboard at the end of that but for
Magnus and Wesley so much on the line
200,000 for the winner the second place
drops down to 100K and that last move by
Magnus taking control of the C5 square
is fighting against Emma Wesley's night
jump we were talking about the C4 square
but the KN could hop onto the center and
then to that uh C5 point which now has
been defended by Magnus how how do you
feel he's evaluating this position is he
thinking of this as something that is
equ or something that he still needs to
defend yeah I've been around Magnus
enough to know that he's not too
bothered about this position probably
his words would be yes I'm slightly
worse yes I'm slightly cramped I'm
suffering but it's holdable and uh I
think right now A draw is H pretty much
what he's dreaming of he wants to move
on to the next one get uh the chance at
the white pieces again despite how the
last game went but uh yeah this last
move it's just good strategy black has a
light squar Bishop so put pawns on dark
squares that way you you cover both
color complexes and Wesley maneuvering
around with his Knight we're looking at
the Rooks potentially they'll be traded
now on the next few turns and yeah I
think Magnus is feeling very confident
should I grab the Hoover or do you want
to grab it I'll grab the
vacuum well we're about to see all of
these pieces be traded uh you can keep
the Rooks on the board that's the the
bit of good news if you're trying to
play for a win but if white takes with
this Rook on D1 Magnus can put his Rook
on the defile okay Wesley takes the
bishop because the Knight can't
currently move but if black slides the
queen on over and protects that Rook
then the Knight can move out of the way
and we could see further trades which
should mean a draw without pieces
remaining on the board it's hard to
attack any of the pawns remaining there
aren't really weaknesses in either
side's Camp I think a draw would be a
fair and likely result at the stage and
with the amount of time they have left
it's really difficult for me to see any
winning chances for either side feels
like the calm after the storm
essentially both players just need a bit
of uh kind of a bit more time to just
compose themselves after the madness
imagine their rates in that previous
game just through the roof and uh there
we go the queen slides across to B7 the
safer Square from Magnus gson defending
his Rook everything's covered the Black
Knight will jump out the way next and
yeah they'll be uh cleaning those pieces
off the board too symmetrical right
right now no pass pawns ever incoming no
weaknesses in either Camp as level as
balanced as you get pretty much in chess
Wesley so trying to get closer to that
Armageddon where things will get more
Rand them it will be about the Battle
for the bids and who gets the black
pieces but before that there will be a
game for and Magnus will have the white
pieces right now both players playing
cautiously trying to just get their
nervous system back into control it was
not only exciting for the fans for the
commentators what we just witnessed in
the earlier game but for these two
players playing that chess especially
down to those seconds those last few
moments absolute uh Insanity on the
board and right now for West he's having
a think about perhaps how to force how
to force matters right now is there a
way that you can actually get the trades
going really quickly Wesley pauses a bit
I think that for Black's next turn is
just going to be moving the night out of
the way and getting all those trades
zaen anyway so I don't think that wesle
needs to force it I think neither side
can make progress because we have a
symmetrical structure and if you're
going to play for more than just the
equality you need to figure out what
side of the board you're stronger on and
neither side is stronger in any
direction there are so few pieces
remaining on this board so few open
files just the two of them here that it
looks likely the Black Knight is going
to jump out of the way and once that
Knight jumps out of the way the Rooks
come off the board and okay well Wesley
can think about sliding his Rook on over
to the G4 square that would threaten
checkm and one but I feel like that's
kind of all you're threatening and once
that's stopped maybe you're just uh
being a little bit tunnel over on the
king side yeah let's jump in and show
this because I don't think anyone was
expecting Wesley to suddenly get
ambitious in such a dry position but
Rook to C4 at least one idea and at
least it will scare Magnus slightly
Force Magnus to go into a think which he
does we see on the camera the black
knight jumping out the way this is the
consistent followup to magnus' plan he
wants to get these Rooks off as soon as
possible a rook trade The rook's
Disappearing this is a dead draw no
chance we'll see this one continue for
much longer but the ambitious move here
for Wesley would be to slide across
threaten the Checkmate on G7 and Robert
I guess you're suggesting just push the
pawn pawn to G6 and yes there's a couple
of darkart squared holes but black
doesn't have to worry too much the white
Knight's never creeping in anytime soon
white doesn't have a dart squared Bishop
to profit from this uh slightly Airy
formation for black and yeah I'm
struggling to see a follow-up if the
White Queen ever Dives in suddenly you
forget whoops I've left myself
vulnerable on the back Rank and actually
no threats against the black monar at
all so uh it just feels like a one idea
trick which doesn't have too much
substance behind it so I think Magnus
after a bit of time to convince himself
will most likely continue his plan it
does make Magnus think a little bit so
it's not perhaps that clear to him if
you just keep the position on the board
and we're talking about and we see this
happen that how can white actually
continue with the pressure If The Rook
Wass to slide on and look at that Wesley
shows ambition in the position he
doesn't immediately trade off and Magnus
doesn't create further dark Square
weaknesses perhaps he wasn't sure about
a knight jump to E5 or eventually the H
Pawn moving forward but he keeps the
position much more solid he puts the
Knight on G6 so blocking the attack and
Wesley Bishop C2 I feel like threats are
on the board this isn't is n as balanced
as we were first thinking it to be but I
can't decide who this is favoring and
sometimes when you play for a win you
jeopardize playing for a loss and if
black just goes Queen C7 here you do
take the Knight and hurt Black's King
side structure but I'll throw in a check
forcing the Queens off the board and the
reason why I could see this and Magnus
plays Queen C7 perhaps even possibil
that white gets in trouble that A3 Pawn
that's quickly going to be targeted all
of White's pieces are over on the king
side now we're getting a double-edged of
position where Black's Pawn structure is
worse but black has easier access to the
weaknesses for white so you have to be
very careful here for both sides but I
think in particular for Wesley we know
how strong Magnus is in the end game
yeah this is really brave from Wesley so
he's still playing really fast right now
uh Wesley up almost 3 minutes on the
clock but after a really stodgy opening
Queen's coming off Roberts line on the
board after a really slow beginning to
this game Wesley's taken risks and we've
headed directly to these closing stages
the end game now but yeah knowing the
opponent Magnus Carson rook and Bishop
tend to do better than rook and Knight
on such an open board as well yes black
has deficiencies in the king side
structure isolated uh Central Pawn for
black but that's far less relevant
White's Queen side is collapsing so I
actually think it's Wesley who might
have to show accuracy right now Black's
moves Black's next moves will be
automatic and uh for Wesley you need to
find ways to drop the White Knight into
the center activate repurpose the white
Rook anyone's game still a three end
game if the Rooks come off the board
Advantage Wesley and that's what he
would like so Knight E5 does attack this
Pawn on G6 but one move Rooks sliding on
the C file offering a trade without
Rooks that light score Bishop for black
can't attack anything at all and then
the damage Pawn structure will be a
downside so I think that for Magnus he
should go after the a pawn we may see
further liquidation and perhaps it's not
too difficult for Wesley but he's the
one who needs to be careful if either of
these players do and a bishop w night
complex it's often about whether you've
got pawns just on one side of the board
or both sides if you've got it on both
Sid it favors the side with the bishop
if you've got pawns only on one side of
the board it favors the side with the
Knight and in this case uh for Wesley he
needs to be a little precise in this end
game he is playing actively puts the
pressure Magnus before going for that
pawn on A3 defends his own Pawn on G6
and this gives Wesley the chance to
offer a rook trade from C4 and you were
against a rook trade for white in this
position but is there another
alternative for Wesley because Rook C3
or Rook A1 is now a big threat and as I
say I also spot that you've got the idea
of going Rook to D4 the central line of
the board and then looking at um ideas
of landing on that eighth rank with a
pin yeah Rook is good for white just to
be clear because now black can't attack
anything um and I feel like Black's
damage Pawn structure not great in the
end game especially if you trade both
the Rooks and the minor pieces you don't
want double Pawns in most end games and
I think after Rooks C4 Magnus is
probably either a Val that I can trade
Rooks and there's not enough material
for Wesley to attack my potentially
loose pawns or he's going to try to keep
the pawns on the board and go after the
queen side but Rook C4 is definitely the
move I'd play for Wesley so you'd go
with Rook C4 what about you would you
decide to keep the Rooks or trade before
I ask Wesley answers he is going for The
Rook trade and Magnus accepts it yeah
I'm glad he had to make that decision
not me but it is instructive we were
just talking about which pieces you want
on the board off the board these top
players that's always going through
their minds thinking long long term
they're not just thinking today these
are my jobs these are my chores they're
thinking what's my life plan in 5 years
time 10 years time they're looking deep
into the future and yeah now Rooks off
the board it's pretty much Knight versus
Bishop Dynamic usually as we mentioned
that would favor the bishop with pawns
on both flanks but here all of whes
Pawns or most of whes Pawns on Dart
squares unattackable unassailable and uh
ultimately it feels like this one should
be level um I'm liking how White's King
could maybe reach the center White's
White's Knight has a beautiful Outpost
but it's just not enough here it's uh
too few weaknesses for either side as
Wesley pushes forward with his pawn and
that's an interesting decision because
traditionally we'd see the doubled Jeep
on and we'd be like that's a weakness in
Black's camp but Wesley with that last
move is actually helping Magnus get rid
of one of those weaknesses I think he
was concerned that magnus's King
especially after kicking the Knight out
of C4 get to D6 and up the board so
quickly and over to the queen side that
he perhaps needed to trade Pawn so his
own King will go to the center and fight
for some key squares so I think both
sides they're playing this extremely
accurately these players do make very
few mistakes so even though we've been
talking about ideas for for Magnus ideas
for Wesley neither side is budging and
we often talk about how Magnus just
creates magic in end games do we see any
hope of that happening in such a
position it's not impossible if the
black king somehow Wiggles its way into
White's Camp uh if the black king gets
more active than its counterparts
certainly black will be uh having the
better chances right now but yeah it's
it's hard to imagine I think Wesley at
some point in the near future will push
the white ewn up one square and actually
form a barrier the black king will not
be able to step past the sixth uh rank
at all so yeah it feels like white will
be able to build a fortras here despite
the fact I've seen Magnus win countless
of these end games this is unlikely to
be one of them and Wesley said his
favorite movie is Lord of the Ring so
Thou shalt not pass is a perfect moment
for him and he should do that he should
just uh clarify end the game on the spot
you don't really want this to continue
although with Magnus getting the white
pieces in the next game it could Tire
him out a little bit and so for Wesley
he knows that this game is a draw not
too much risk for him to just make some
more moves both players have so much
time though that I don't see them
getting into trouble yeah we mentioned
that this tournament is a marathon who
do you think has the better stamina it's
been such a long week long eight days
actually for both of them if it does get
down to this final game assuming this
one is going to be a draw now I'm
expecting Wesley to push his Pawn
forward in the center if this one's a
draw if the next wants to draw
Armageddon can Wesley take it I I think
that's a dream for Wesley right to get
to Armageddon to make things more random
and you said stamina a factor energy a
factor so who is more fit right now and
I wonder if that means that maybe a
chess boxing match between the two would
decide we saw an earlier interview where
Magnus said it would take $10 million
for an offer to uh for him to play for
him to go into chess boxing I think
that's a fair price to see
that I mean if I had $10 million to
spare
pretty sure I need to I need 9,000 9
million then yeah if anyone's watching
who's got $10 million that's one that I
think everyone would want to see Magnus
Carlson in chess boxing but I think I
agree with you David stamina energy is
such a factor right now and for both
players to have this calm game it's
perhaps exactly what they need for this
match to progress further because it's
not only game by game right it's also
what happens during the game game two
was such a I I'm struggling for a word
but something just takes that energy out
of you that physical that emotional
energy out of you with the decisions
that you have to make it was a barn
burner it was a melee and neither side
you know wants to expend that much
energy when there are more games to come
and I'm actually looking at this
position with Keen interest because
Wesley should bring his Knight back as
David was saying make sure that the
black king can't enter but if black gets
a free move that Bishop is actually
going to go all the way down the board
to F1 to start pestering White's King
side pawns and the black king will start
entering on the queen side so Wesley
does need to be a little bit careful
here but if he exercises that caution
and brings his Knight back the game
should be a draw because then the black
king cannot enter but you can see Wesley
he knows that this is a a moment where
he cannot take his foot off the pedal
yeah he's wondering whether to take a
risk whether to go in with the white
king but if it becomes a race if Black's
Bishop does come in and start picking
off White's pawns on light squares on
the king side then Black's Bishop will
be superior to the White Knight simply
with pawns running on both flanks so he
does drop back the Knight that shake of
the head was acknowledgement that this
one is going to be a dead draw any
moment now the White Knight is the one
forming the barrier with the pawns and
thou shalt not pass for either side yeah
that Knight on C3 and that pawn on B4
just taking away so many key squares for
the black king to move forward unless we
see black striking with the a pawn
moving up two steps but perhaps white
just keeps the tension as it is if there
is an offer of a pwn trade on the queen
side you want to keep the formation as
it is not allowing magnus's King forward
whenever I see an end game and I see
Magnus on one side of it you still have
to be so careful until the very end one
one minor inaccuracy and everything
turns around the good news for Wesley is
it's almost impossible to make an
inaccuracy it would seem because that
King you could let it get a few free
turns it's not going anywhere white has
a fortress Magnus famously doesn't
believe in Fortress he says it as a jest
uh I think and you see wesle he's not
even looking at the board anymore
because now that he's got his night on
C3 and those Pawns in the dark squares
the bishop can't attack any of them it's
inherently limited to whatever on the
light squares the king for black can't
enter anymore so now it's Shuffle time
that's really instructive just place
your pawns on the opposite color of your
opponent's Bishop make sure that there
is no entry point and now the king just
moves around and we can see that black
can offer trades but white can just keep
the tension as it is and it will be um
it will head down to a draw do you think
Wesley at this moment is already
thinking about his game four strategy
potentially uh he's at least trying to
conserve energy I think he's just uh
looking into the future and maybe even
wondering about that Armageddon if he
gets that far um this one yeah there's
zero life look at white everything on
Dart squares he's playing checkers and
unfortunately for Magnus Carson right
now this is a deadlock uh just no way to
break the barrier but yeah he must be
planning ahead now Wesley so he's still
got plenty of time on the clock 5
minutes is just more than enough right
now and when we talk about trying to
break a barrier we're looking at Pawn
breaks from black here and there are two
that come to mind right like the a a
pawn can move forward to steps to A5 or
the G Pawn can move forward to G5 break
that down for us how should Wesley react
to make sure that black sking doesn't
get more activity if a break was to
arrive um yeah I think just ignore
everything just leave everything don't
touch it I'm sorry that I was just
playing around trying to figure out if
there was anything at all black could uh
try but the answer is no um I don't know
if Magnus will even try to test just
keep the white king just move back and
forth back and forth you'll never get
zuk swi because I think black won't be
able to create enough threats it's a
fortress Magnus will believe in it if he
doesn't already because there is nothing
he can do and that black king may go on
over to the F5 square and then try to go
into G4 like you go there and there and
you're going down towards the pawns and
the white king just steps back and
defends them so the control of the dark
squares is completely in Wesley's favor
and he's shuffling back and forth Magnus
very much doing the same I don't see any
inroads and I believe both players they'
be well served with a draw offer in the
near future every day they're shuffling
is going to shuffle as well not much to
do though White's King will always block
out shoulder off its counterpart the
black king can come one square forward
but no further and uh yeah Wesley doing
the right thing once the black king is
distracted on the other flank find a way
to repeat yeah there we go it's a draw a
handshake and uh very level game this
one very peaceful draw this one from
start to fin the players just calming
down after the chaos of game two Magnus
Carlson with the black pastes holds the
draw Wesley from the start never really
got an edge he pushed a little with some
ideas but never anything to worry about
for black hyper accurate chest that's
what's on display here in the Champions
chess tort finals title match Magnus
Carlson he's got a little more pep in
his step and that's not just because he
talked to Pep Guardiola the other day
it's because he won set one here in set
two it's tied one after one F and he
gets the white pieces in game four and
that will be the final rapid game if it
ends in a tie we will have the bidding
Armageddon but the big question right
now will Magnus Carlson try to wrap it
up with white will he get ambitious or
will he have the same strategy as Wesley
of trying to mix things up go into
chaotic grounds with Armageddon my gut
feeling is Magnus with white will take
his chances but they with this game
three there were no chances for E
decides minimal chances I just wanted to
highlight one brief moment where Wesley
did try something he tried to spice it
up but Magnus Carson had all the answers
and quickly shut down the game he
quickly guided it towards safety and it
was here where Wesley with a bit of
misdirect he had been playing very
quietly very slowly looked like he was
ready to already offer a draw but
suddenly he threw a spanner in the W
Rook to C4 trying to slide across and he
even threatened Checkmate the queen Rook
lined up against the black king but
Magnus Carlson is too strong a Defender
white only has two attacking pieces is
not sufficient to crash through and
after Knight to G6 this was the key move
Queen to C7 and after Bishop takes
Knight what we call a vision so an
intermediate move not taking back
allowing white another move to continue
the initiative first forcing the Queens
off the board no attack any longer and a
dead level end game and it was held with
no problems from either side but a great
awareness of both players for Wesley
just a challenge Magnus for a move and
for Magnus say I'm going to Parry that
threat trade the queens and no risk
ahead so I think that both players play
great game I would not be surprised that
was like 99% accuracy from both them
highle chess here in Toronto chess is a
simple game when two of the best players
play no one makes a mistake it ends in a
draw but the next one is going to be a
big one and we saw after game two fans
in Toronto in the fan Zone celebrated
Wesley's big win and we are going to
check in with the fans and with James KY
James that was a slow game three I hope
everyone got their drink and are ready
for the
action oh of course yeah I actually went
to sleep on the way here watching the
game actually I was uh walking but sleep
at the same time got here people was
napping talking about what they going to
eat for lunch and stuff you hear the
conversation back there the game was
absolutely boring but at the same time
it is armagedon now we now we have more
chests we're going to have another game
so that's going to be hype and people
are here having a good time having
drinks and you know looking at this game
and this match so we got a game for
Tanya so we're happy oh so excited in
the studio as well because our big
question is is Magnus going to go all
out with white or will it go to
Armageddon prediction there James oh
Magnus was white yeah prediction wise um
I actually saw that Wesley was like oh I
want to go to Armageddon here let's try
to get into it feels like he's a little
bit more confident but if Magnus is able
to turn it up just a little bit we may
actually see a a decisive result in the
fourth round I'm going to say we
actually are going to see a decisive
result in this fourth game here I'm I'm
going say Magnus is winning um yeah I
say Magnus wins what do you think Tanya
well James I'm going to save Tanya from
that question cuz I'm wondering how's
your tongue I mean do you still feel
that Spice from The Challenge with
Levy yeah in fact I did uh yeah it was
pretty bad we had Medics on staff so
they took me in they took my vitals make
sure I was good for the day you know cuz
uh Levy almost died as well right so it
it's fine you know we we did not have to
like um uh call out on chess.com and get
them in trouble or anything because we
have insurance with them so we're good
so they paid our Med our medical bills
and we're good to go you know so it did
hurt it did hurt did hurt and uh James
I'm I'm glad it was you who dropped the
b word uh not me do you think this next
game will be as boring as the previous
one you predicted Magnus to win how do
you think he's going to do
it you know it's probably maybe with a
C4 C4 a lot of weird things happen with
C4 many ways that you can go D4 is fun
too as well E4 okay they say best bu
test but E4 hasn't been scoring as much
as we would like it to or as much as
fans at home like to see E4 with
decisive games and openness and stuff
like that but maybe we'll see some C4
maybe we'll see Knight F3 and see a
Catalin like you like to play David and
put us all asleep but at the same time I
think we will have ourselves not an
armag a decisive result by Magnus in the
fourth round fourth game James you just
predicted every possible opening with
white I mean hey something's going to
happen there Tanya we don't know how but
we just know it is and people at home
actually feel probably the same way we
do want to see an armag get in but for
some reason I just feel like we're going
to see that decisive Resort by Magnus
all right we will find out very soon
James we check in with you later have a
fun time
there thank
you James KY in the fan Zone and there's
more fun news coming up for the fans
across the world Magnus Carlson is not
only defend defending his Champions
chest St title right now but later he
will be defending his rapid and Blitz
world championship title as he will be
in the world rapid and Blitz starting
December
26th mark your calendars and right now
you got to stick around because the
action's getting hot in this
[Music]
city I'm here with Magnus Carlson world
number one and to many greatest chess
player of all time we're going to ask
him a few questions I'm going to name a
sport you have to tell me the greatest
of all time mhm sounds good yeah
basketball
LeBron
James soccer Messi I agree with both
baseball Barry
bondes what did he say Okay football
like American
football Tom Brady I guess okay yeah
good one uh tennis jokovic was it always
jokovic for you you thought maybe no it
was after the um Australian Open thing
that he became the greatest for me was
it Nadal before or feder probably fed
but I always identified more with the
way than ad Doll place
Golf Tiger Fair poker dog
Brunson that's a unique one
chess gar Kasparov are you allowed to
say
yourself I don't know if I'm allowed but
I think Gary is the best of all time
still CH
boxing
I'm on Hamilton I agree we're going to
play this or that would you rather go on
a cruise or a road trip road trip comedy
or thriller comedy coffee or tea tea but
only slightly preferably neither how do
you get energized the
sun cats or dogs cats but I like dogs
too it's like a this or that is a little
bit tough with you you like everything
shower or bath oh shower for sure okay I
don't have the patience to take baths
are you a morning person or a night owl
Night Owl for sure would you rather get
on a phone call or text message text
probably I feel like the answer for you
is neither feel like it's just usually
yes just go sunrise or sunset sunrise
winter or summer summer sauna or ice
bath both okay that that's what you do
in in Norway that you go in the SAA and
then you take an ice bath and then you
go back in the SAA and you do that a few
times it's really nice how many beers
would it take for you to drink for me to
beat you in a classical chess game
that's a very difficult question uh cuz
I'd probably sober up during the game so
I'd probably have to keep drinking
probably start with 20 and take it from
there 20 okay how what's the size of the
cup um pints wow okay 20 name your price
if you have to chess box um $10 million
do you prefer to play chess on uh
computer over the board or on your phone
I rarely play on my phone I I would say
I prefer to play on the computer in your
entire career have you ever had a day
where you went I think this guy might be
as good as me in
chess
no uh well I mean not not not you know
since not the last 10 years for sure
okay has it ever
been this guy might be kind of close to
me if I have a bad day yeah uh I would
say Fabia his best was um very close in
In classical for sure my other question
was going to be who do you think is the
second best chess player in the world so
I suppose yeah I think Fabiana Coran is
the is the second second best player
thank you Magnus for sitting down with
us and doing these rapid fire questions
now get out of
here
[Music]
and a big congratulations to the winner
of our air things device it's Lucille
congrats and you get an air things
signed by the himself Magnus Carlson it
is coming your way to help you keep your
air quality in check so you can play
amazing chess as well also amazing photo
also really cute dog there and speaking
of the goat himself Magnus Carlson will
be getting ready with the white pieces
for the upcoming Final fourth rapid game
of the second set Magnus will he go for
more that is the big question game three
did end and peacefully in a draw not too
much drama and to get into the mindset
uh of what the players are bringing on
Ka ask some questions to
Magnus still tied after a draw in this
game was that a good for result for you
now Magnus after losing game two yeah it
was okay what was we saw you very angry
after um game two how difficult is it to
come into game three there and and just
get a game
going it's okay I mean it's it's a new
game um
obviously it was
uh um yeah game two was uh was not so
good but yeah I could sort of see it
coming in that my in that my play in
game one in time Trel was really shaky
and this time again I mean he did a good
job to create serious imbalances uh I
thought I maybe I thought my position
was a little bit better than it actually
was and then you know it got completely
out of control how do you feel about
your play today overall all pretty poor
but still you know got a good chance mhm
and um a game four coming up here with a
white pieces Wesley been very open that
he thinks um it's an advantage for him
to take it to Armageddon what do you
think for for your sake we'll see we see
do you have a big plan for game four
here with white pieces we'll see we'll
see all right well we'll see what
happens in game four minus we have the
white pieces will it be Armageddon or
will it be decided back to you guys
yeah Magnus Carlson not giving any of
his strategy away for the upcoming game
for but he did mention that he felt that
the play was shaky during time trouble
there Robert it was shaky and time
trouble but he is not shaky with the
white pieces he did his James Harden
interview walk away and he looks like a
vintage James Harden win rate at 64% the
best in the Champions chess tour he's
got eight wins with the white pieces why
not make it nine so Magnus Carlson with
the white piece is a dangerous dangerous
man yeah Magnus with white is probably
the most dangerous player in World Chess
but it's not just that Magnus will get
to dictate the nature of play if he can
I think Magnus will take as much risk
out while still applying some pressure
and for Wesley that's psychologically
tough a draw for him would be great get
to the arm again but it's not going to
be given to him we saw Wesley take these
big risks with the black pieces in game
two and Magnus was white in that one but
now given a different Dynamic of the
match are we expecting a more cautious
approach from Wesley and not go all out
I think that Magnus was actually a
little bit too passive in his opening
choice in that second game and then
Wesley's looking at the position like
okay you now have to save your Bishop
I'm going to win a pawn so for Magnus
Carlson I think he'll play something a
little bit more Mainline not taking huge
risks but at least playing something
he's more familiar and thus more
comfortable with he did start with the
Kings spawn opening in game too and it's
going to be big questions to Magnus what
will his approach be right now does he
want to take it to Armageddon or does he
want to make the most of the white
pieces there's so much on the line for
these two players there is of course the
$200,000 for the winner more than that
just the glory of being the Undisputed
King of the Champions Chester what are
we hoping for we always want more chess
more chess we want the Armageddon we
want maybe I'll whisper it quietly
magnet uh Wesley to strike back and we
get another reset we get another set we
get more chess more action I'm not
rooting for anybody but who doesn't love
extra let's get overtime let's get more
and more chess and I think these players
really are just showing a tremendous
fight so how can we not be happy Magnus
are in his interview with K he
definitely looked a bit a bit angry with
himself for what he had let slip the
match could have been over by now had he
not lost that game that's what they say
right accidents always happen when
you're nearing home when you're in that
final stages in Magnus he probably had
that Finishing Line in sight he'd
already won with black that's that's a
huge stepping stone and I mean what more
could he have asked for but suddenly
getting that knockback with white it's
anyone's game now Magnus yeah he cannot
write this one off he still has a real
fight on his hands that was a big big
wakeup call by Wesley punching with the
black pieces in game two and Wesley gets
the black pieces one more time in this
final game I'm much more confident
Wesley walking in it could be his final
game here at the Champions chestor
finals right this is his life on the
line and for Wesley so he's been so
solid as James likes to say but it's
been shaky in the finals that's what
happens when you're playing Magnus
Carlson after that game one loss this is
the most that Wesley could have hoped
for striking back with black a slow
solid game in game three keeping
everything under control never coming in
any kind of pressure Wesley there would
just oh he's not happy with the H Pawn
Yeah it's hurting my ears because he's
slamming that down you think he's going
to use herry the H Pawn in this game
quite possibly uh he has done in the
past and uneven yeah it was uneven
Wesley s
say will we see that having fun yeah it
gave us trouble in like a few rounds
before it was yeah uneven okay it's good
now yeah like it was making a r okay
sounds good all a sudden it was showing
up as a queen oh okay but we cut it like
between the games so yeah I put it there
on
G7 Wesley knocking the pieces
he knows there's a microphone nearby
he's he was he was a fan favorite until
he did all this it's hurting everybody's
ears Wesley come on give us a break it
with the queen can I BL my with the
queen no that's not allowed
Wesley I think we all catch
that and then it'll show
up oh my does show up with some food in
his mouth right now and he will be ready
to go Wesley there knocking the pieces
will we see some knockout blows being
played out on the chess board as well
and in just a few seconds we will have
the first moves uh the players getting
ready the glasses come back on and we
will have handshakes and moves just on
the board and it's go time again for
Magnus what will be his first move will
it be the best five test one E4 lot of
adjusting going on this
time and we have the handshake which
Pawn will Magnus Carlson push it's the
queen Pawn the D pawn and Wesley reacts
instantly by bringing his Knight out
much more classical stuff Magnus might
have lost his last opportunity to play 1
B3 on the Champions chest this season
with white but here we go one of the
main lines of the Queen's Gambit the
Berlin of 1 D4 as we call it where often
Queens get traded off very early Magnus
Carlson defeated Fabiano Carana in this
opening just a couple of days ago but
this time he pushes his Knight to the
more normal Square not the Central
Square that he used against Fabiano and
uh this is a very well-known position
Robert yeah for here Wesley so brings
his Bishop out white can take this
bishop on E6 at any moment but first
Magnus goes Bishop D2 and to my eyes
that's a bit of an odd move because
white wants to Castle the king towards
the queen side and get a rook check
along the defile but that Bishop will
block the rook's path so Bishop D2 a
very interesting move here just kind of
throwing a curveball at Wesley yeah
again it feels like one of those
openings Magnus Carson he's just testing
the opponent this is modern chess uh
often the top players they study these
types of openings these forcing lines
with Queens coming off center opening
they study them for tens of hours
hundreds of hours even and uh often they
know everything under the sun in the
main lines but if you test them with
these small ideas these oddl looking
ideas White's Bishop on a really passive
Square uh then actually the opponents do
have scope to go wrong that's what
happened when Magnus met Fabiano a few
days ago and look at that Wesley just
peering off at the opponent how much
does Magnus know Wesley has got to
assume he's walking into some
preparation so just surviving these next
few moves will be step one for Wesley so
first question on the board by Magnus
Carlson as he plays a non-standard move
in this position definitely an opening
that Wesley knows so well is so familiar
with but yet it makes him pause and burn
some time on the clock it's all about
finding the right setup for your pieces
here with black and also we shouldn't be
fooled by the Queens being traded off
this isn't Magnus being non- ambitious
or just going into an Armageddon he
wants to try to grind down this end game
he's going to play this out till the
very end it's a really clever move
actually if we dive into the specifics a
bit it does take away one of Black's Key
Resources with the dark Square bishop
and the threat if you want to call it
that or at least the idea of Knight
takes Bishop from White Tak this bishop
near the black king side that's not out
of the question either so he just plays
a tricky move order Wesley develops his
Knight the E4 Pawn can be grabbed the
white king can Castle Queens out if he
wants but he first takes this Pawn E4
and he has equalized the material but
Magnus has the right to Castle while
Wesley does not yeah that black king
could come under heavy fire yes the
Queens are off there's not going to be
direct check mate attacks but if you
imagine white castling the white Rooks
centralizing Black's King will be caught
in no man's land and so right now it's
looking very very level it's just the
lack of castling rights for black but
there is also a bit of a threat of
White's Knight going back where it came
from if White's ever able to trade off
White's Knight White's Knight sorry for
a Black's light squared Bishop a
long-term Advantage it's all about the
bishop pair here symmetrical Pawn
structure just as we saw pretty much in
the previous game um this one risk of it
fizzling out but only if Wesley is
accurate it's definitely onus on black
here to defend this one Magnus he's
trying to play for two results he's
trying to take all risk out while
massaging a small but stable long-term
advantage and we might see Wesley on the
next move fighting that very threat that
David you pointed out to he does reach
for the H Pawn so keeping control of the
G5 Square now there's no more Knight
jumping trying to grab that Bishop air
which in this position especially being
so open with pawns on both side will
really count for something so with
Knight G5 out of the question now it's
time for Magnus to decide where does he
want to place his King if you go
castling on the Queen's side you have to
calculate lines of giving up the A2 Pawn
the Magnus also has the idea that he can
just continue with development and it
still feels he'll be the one to control
the central lines first take out that
Bishop Castle on the king side looks
like the safer option to me and both of
his Bishops can get to the longest
diagonal so is Bishop on D2 the dark
Square Bishop it can just go one square
uh to the left hand side that way and go
to C3 on the long dangle the light
Square Bishop can step in front of the
King right now and then also go to F3 so
both of his Bishops will be on good
squares and I think he should delay his
decision of where to Castle keep Wesley
on his toes so that Wesley doesn't know
which side of the board to focus on yeah
Wesley really shouldn't react uh kind of
react even relax too soon in this game
because uh these positions are deceptive
I've been on the wrong end against these
top top Grand Masters Magnus has ground
me down multiple times these top players
they always look for resources no matter
how drawish it looks you cannot assume
you'll get the draw and uh definitely
small ideas here for white we're not
seeing much for black not too many
active plans here Wesley still needs
three or four things to happen he needs
to get the black king safe needs to get
the black d squid BR out connect his
Rooks bring them to the center but there
we go uh Robert's move this is the ideal
home the ideal perch for white start
Square Bishop look at the pressure it
exerts on the long diagonal and lines
towards the black king the center is so
open that this is a tactical type of end
game and still I feel like this one will
be much more exciting than the previous
battle we saw um still chances for white
I refer to these types of positions as
queenless middle games because there are
attacking chances when I hear endgame I
think Pawn races is someone going to be
able to promote what trades should we
offer the the question of the trades is
a good one black can't easily trade
pieces because the king is in the center
there's no right to Castle any longer
white on the other hand can Castle
queenside put a rook directly in the
path of the black king that light Square
Bishop can go out to E2 or D3 to protect
the knight in the center I think black's
choices are harder here and that dark
Square Bishop for Wesley the bishop on
f8 can't easily develop either because
the white Bishop on C3 is staring at
that pawn on G7 so difficult decisions
ahead for Wesley so well he does take
one he does line up The Rook on the C
file so discouraging Magnus for now at
least to go Castle on the queen side cuz
that would pin that white Bishop on C3
once the king and the Rook are lined up
allowing uh Wesley to finish his own
development of the dark Squad Bishop so
with longside castling out of the
question right now the big thing from
for Magnus is to decide where he wants
to place the other Bishop how does he
decide to get it into the diagonal that
you were earlier alluding to does he
simply put it in front of the king try
to get his King to safety on the king's
side how do you see this progressing
yeah Robert was advocating this bishop
maneuver looks very natural uh what else
for white here I guess you could try to
come out to be5 put some pressure on but
you're not really threatening anything
and uh yeah I'm advocating this bishop
move too um yeah just to point out we
cannot really Castle right now because
they at the very least for black there
will be ideas of bringing the bishop out
and putting some pressure on this pinned
piece um also hanging A2 if Wesley is
feeling greedy just like he did a bit
earlier today to grab a pawn but yeah
I'm expecting Magnus to keep his options
open just improve this piece land it on
this long diagonal just in case it
becomes open later and Magnus he is the
one in move I'm not sure he really wants
to Castle kingside either because the
white king will be so far away from the
center there but it's all about the
quick development here instead and I'd
be wondering if I'm Wesley let's say
white does move Bishop E2 can black play
a little B copycat Play Bishop E7 I
understand I've just blundered a Pawn on
G7 but after Rook to G8 now the G2 Pawn
is also loose so you can take this H6
Pawn as well and now we're getting into
this type of game where does black have
that compensation that CW that nobody
likes black is down material but has
really active pieces particular this
Rook on G2 The Rook on C8 is also
looking pretty good a bishop B4 check at
any moment could kick the king out of
the center so is it ficient
compensation I don't think so the
evaluation Bar says that white is better
I would be looking at this and also
thinking the same because Black's forces
they're not coordinated they're not as
harmonious as you'd like and he's
reaching for his Bishop but at least he
was Magnus Carlson he lands it on D3 uh
a bit of an odd Choice here I would say
because it does block the defile but
maybe he's simply arguing that longterm
the bishop has more potential on this
Square um after all two Bishops standing
next to each other do control a lot of
squares pointing in this direction just
making it maybe slightly more Awkward
for black to develop on that flank uh
later on so he is getting ready Magnus
to Castle his King one thing Wesley
could try is to try uh trade off Knights
but this might not actually help long
term uh for example if we do see a trade
Black's Bishop still stuck defending
this Pawn Rook takes Knight now finally
white will get the king castled and this
queenless middle game as Robert coined
uh as Robert termed it um yeah actually
deceptively dangerous for black this
black king still not safe this black
Bishop still sorry TI down to the G7
Pawn Advantage
white and Wesley's for right there he's
leaning in he's moved closer to the
board it's different from the kind of
stuff the body language that we've been
seeing from him so far definitely more
at EAS with the Matt situation that's on
right now Magnus back in his chair he's
in his territory he's in his comfort
zone it's an end game that he can play
on forever he can try to find those
small minute Advantage longterm uh he's
feeling comfortable as well what does
this give away about the Matt strategy
because Wesley again just coming back to
his interview happy to go to Armageddon
mag Magnus revealed nothing he just said
we'll see what happens the chest that
we're seeing right now what does that
tell us I think he meant it that it
depending on what Wesley would play if
Wesley played some really solid line
where uh there weren't too many PS in
the position mag said okay take a draw
send to Armageddon but as David coined
it himself he said this is like the
Berlin of 1 dd4 but this is like the
best possible Berlin from the white side
the position is open black has lost the
right to Castle there are these open
files the white Rooks are about to
occupy the dark sore Bishop for black
stuck at home unless you want to give up
a pawn I wouldn't want to give up a pawn
against Magnus Carlson and I think this
bishop on D3 it just preemptively
defends the knight in the center if
black had any ideas to move that light
score Bishop to D5 or something like
that so I think Magnus just controls the
board the dark score Bishop for him once
he cast can also go to D4 and he's
staring in both directions in a way that
Wesley's pieces aren't huge Advantage I
I see the evaluation bar it's saying
like I can't I can't read it but
something like 0 five let's call it half
a pawn better for white this looks from
a practical point of view much much
better for magna's great winning chances
yeah the White Knight better more active
than the Black Knight White's two
Bishops clearly superior to the black
bishops it's these small things that do
add up so not a full Pawn Advantage we
don't see anything dramatic happening on
the board but the top players they're
very aware they're kind of zoned into
these almost imperceptible advantages
and Magnus feeling comfortable I just uh
I have a feeling he studied this type of
position in the past we talked about
Styles in previous games game two that
was decided that Wesley won that was
just a mess nobody liked that type of
position both equally uncomfortable the
previous game suited them both this one
suits Magnus down to a T he loves
grinding out these small advantages he
loves risk three positions and Wesley
here he's got got a really really tough
task on his hands that being said if
Wesley does go on to draw this game he
will be feeling it in the Armageddon
yeah but right now he needs to make a
decision he can't burn too much time on
the clock right now he can't let Magnus
break away uh on the clock the way it's
happening right now because again Magnus
isn't going to agree for a quick draw
with trading off pieces really quickly
he's going to keep the game going he's
going to keep the options open so for
Wesley to have those extra minutes will
be important right now in about what is
that almost a four minute think after
this development of the bishop and the
reason for that is that Wesley has to
find a way to find Harmony between his
pieces to finish that development to
find the right Square for that Bishop on
f8 which right now finds it impossible
to come out because of the pressure on
that G7 Pawn the Rooks still haven't
found a way to come onto the open file
The h8 Rook is still out of the game the
Knight on D7 is still fine it's doing
its job but that King on d8 not feeling
absolutely safe it needs to get out of
the way and it just feels like the
pieces are coming in its own way you you
don't want to step up with the King to
E7 and he makes this move but this move
just seems to leave behind a lot of
light Square weaknesses in Black's Camp
he also could have played this move when
he played Pawn to H6 so I think Wesley
might be regretting his earlier move at
the point of H6 earlier was to take away
Knight G5 this F6 move takes away the G5
square and blunts that dark squore
Bishop on C3 so it kind of was a Tempo
losing move and not just that it hands
the light squares look at the Swiss
cheese formation on the king side in
mags's favor he castles very simple move
his Rooks will come to the center but I
do think a few turns ago if we want to
just rewind for a moment here that when
he went H6 he could have played Pawn to
F6 and that would have freed up his Dark
Sword Bishop earlier and his King maybe
could have run over to the F7 square and
just tucked it away there I think I
missed opportunity from Wesley and these
small mistakes ones that don't look
obvious it doesn't even look like it was
a bad move these cost you against mag
Carlson yeah I just wanted to highlight
the Swiss cheese you mentioned here
Robert uh lots of holes here and
especially on the light squares but
Wesley has found uh a decent maneuver to
try and plug those holes to block them
up King to F7 is something you mentioned
in the previous position yes he could
have saved a move yes he could have done
this all a lot quicker worly so but if
he gets the king to the square maybe uh
he's holding everything together
everything would then be protected the
king would be off all of the open lines
in the center and yes uh it's kind of
not ideal yes he might have made some
small slip ups but the top players
they're so good at doing this they admit
their mistake Wesley will have known
that he could have saved a move and he's
found the best uh the best solution in
this tough position we were talking
about where to place pieces and Wesley
shows the way the king will slide over
to that square now that White's Bishop
is blunt the dark Square Bishop will
also find itself in the game uh they
still not easy because that Knight on e4
controls a lot of key developing squares
for the bishop Magnus takes a thing but
for me the first move come to mind is to
just slide The Rook to the open files in
the center line it up with the bishop
and the king or perhaps on the D file
but I think it's the followup it's the
plan what do you want to do next yes you
can play a rook from F1 next to the king
uh all the way to the open E line but
how does that really help once black
steps up with the king I think the Rooks
can go the open files at any moment and
because the black king is going to F7 a
very Magnus likee idea is pushing Harry
the H Pawn and that H Pawn can go up to
H4 and then up to even further H5 and
the point is you are taking control of
that swiss cheese formation now I want
to land a bishop on G6 because if I get
a bishop there I could get some back
rank checkm ideas the position for black
remains pretty solid there's maybe a
weakness or two in this setup but for
Wesley he has done all right to just
play Bishop E7 complete his development
and so some of the advantages for white
will be longterm you see that the
evaluation Mar prefers white and I think
everyone else uh who's just looking at
the position would too but I think that
Wesley he's doing a great job of one
mistake won't necessarily cost him the
game it may put him on the back foot but
Wesley's a great defender he is one of
the most accurate players in chess
history yeah and such an accurate
defense there to play F6 to put the King
on F7 I guess if white pushes the pawn
maybe black might consider doing the
same and uh the only downside for black
this Pawn being slightly weak long term
But ultimately Wesley still in decent
shape here and uh he still has to be the
favorite to hold this one and uh Magnus
the time is now to try and transform his
Advantage we've been talking about all
these intangible things all these small
things adding up he needs to transform
it into something uh more concrete
whether that's a porn Advantage whether
that's control over some squares or the
bishop pair that's why Magnus has gone
into the tank now for over 3 minutes
feels like it's the first critical
moment where it's the first difficult
decision for Magnus Carlson and the
clock is leveling out as Magnus does
make his decision on this move does he
start advancing the hbor or does he
continue with the more standard Rooks
bringing them in the center meanwhile
Black's Knight Wesley's Knight can also
jump onto the center of the board at
some point asking questions but really
impressive how Wesley uh slowed down but
then blitzed out the move showing that
he knows what he's doing he knows the
structure that he wants to go to I've
still got my eyes out on those strange
pawns on the king side for black that F6
H6 and I just wonder if that for Magnus
is some sort of a signal and gives him a
little bit of a hope of trying to push
out in this end game cuz that's the only
the only non-standard thing that I see
about this position the light Squad
weaknesses yeah his antenna is up he's
recognizing that there are problems in
Black's position but can he actually
capitalize is a completely different one
so we're looking at this position we
want to put a Rooks in the open files
but Black's setup is actually quite
solid the foundation of it the bishop on
E6 protects the Knight on D7 the king
going to F7 also protects the bishop on
E6 and as soon as that dark squore
Bishop develops and the Rooks are
connected and a second Rook is brought
towards the center I do think that at
that stage Wesley would be like all
right I've got this but until that
moment like Magnus will try to push and
if Wesley can stabilize as we I said
earlier a draw is not the worst thing in
the world for Magnus Carlson just sends
us the arm again and we're talking about
all these light Squad weaknesses as
being the only hope in White's position
can Magnus think about a plan of
retreating with that Knight to G3 and
trying to put that Knight on a more
active Square in Black's Camp I'm eying
F5 yeah I like that maneuver sometimes
you got to go back to go forward uh so
White's Knight looks like the pride and
joy right now it's the most advanced
pece for white but oh he Retreats a
bishop instead so similar idea he's
going for some light squares he's trying
to probe a big check potentially in the
air if White's Bishop lands on the H5
Square hitting the black king but uh
yeah somehow pieces even if they look
ideally placed they need a purpose they
need to be actually threatening doing
something uh so these Knight Retreats
Bishop Retreats Magnus he's hinting at
uh some attacking ideas and he wants his
Rook to do something when it lands on D1
he probably didn't see much happening on
the E file but if a rook slides the D1
Now The Bishop's out of the way let's
say King to F7 just to stop any kind of
Bishop H5 funny business after Rook D1
now Knight D6 check is an idea let me
get the two Bishops advantage and here
it is an advantage for white because you
play with a free hand their pawns on
both sides of the board it's still an
active uh setup for white so I think
that this was a good call by mag he
takes one step backwards with the bishop
but it allows his Knight to hop forwards
in the ensuing sequence yeah uh I love
it too I must admit and this idea of the
bishop check it's not threatening
anything now because this can simply be
blocked but this would loosen up black
structure and even if it doesn't happen
now Wesley has to watch out for it on
the next five six even 10 moves down the
future it's always nice to have this
idea up your sleeve your opponent will
burn 5 Seconds uh every move calculating
it working it out and just watch out for
it to uh become a bigger Factor later in
the game suddenly when he least suspects
it weslio might have to face this type
of check but first of all the most
natural move looks like occupying the
defile I'm saying this Rook maybe the
other Rook as well this would at some
point allow black to potentially grab a
pawn but not right now because the black
Bishop tied down to this night so Magnus
uh maybe choosing which Rook that's
always the question I struggle with most
in chess which Rook to plant on an open
file looks like you have a choice of two
and uh it's just about where the
remaining Rook would want to end up
later on really interesting concept by
Magnus to fall back with the bishop and
eventually finding a way to create an
imbalance in the position if white is
able to trade the Knight with the Bishop
then we're talking about a game then
we're talking about a long-term Edge
already but to me it's surprising that
Magnus took a long thing for the bishop
to fall down but now again he goes into
the think and it could be about deciding
which Rook but that's a big burn on the
clock the last two moves there's no risk
in the position but we are seeing some
hesitation from Magnus and if the times
were reversed then Wesley would be
feeling very nervous about his chances
but with Wesley playing moves quickly
and strong moves at that Magnus is Maybe
looking at this like do I actually have
much of anything here can I press
forward for the win I think putting a
rook on the defile makes the most sense
it's uh in line with what he just did
Bishop E2 retreating so I would play
Rook to D1 and then try to get the two
Bishops Advantage whether you can win
that position is a whole another story
Wesley so a brilliant Defender but
Magnus just take this pluses where they
come yeah feels like he's overthinking
Magnus gson maybe a bit frustrated that
he doesn't see anything direct uh in the
end he wow pushes a pawn so he really
wants toight this game really wants some
Advantage Magnus Carson because this is
a bit weakening White's pawn move
suddenly White's King is vulnerable
suddenly you leave a bunch of squares uh
unprotected uh in your own camp but he's
trying to step forward destabilizing
Black's light Square bishop and watch
out that black king on light squares if
white gets the pawn one square forward
uh to F5 big big threats appear so okay
the evaluation bar doesn't react it's
not a bad move it's not uh kind of a
winning move either but it is asking
questions of Wesley he's just trying to
pose practical problems love that move
and I didn't see it I wouldn't have
played it I didn't suggest it but that
move is trying to push forward to F5 so
that you really control all of the light
squares and if black tries to stop that
at once with say the move G6 just to
cover the square instead of putting a
Pawn on the Square now I think the
Knight can even go back to g3 at any
moment I'm going to play F5 myself and I
shattering your Pawn structure on the
king's side so we talk about small
pluses this suddenly becomes a pretty
important plus for white that if black
would be forced to get rid of the G Pawn
for White's pawn two isolated pawns
remaining in the position for black
completely unideal and another Pawn
decision that you never want to make to
stop this idea of F5 is to go F5
yourself to fix the pawn on that square
because then that Bishop on C3 becomes
such a strong piece you can give a check
on H5 G6 is impossible anymore The Rook
is hanging on h8 and forcing black to go
back to G8 making sure that that Rook on
h8 is stuck fall back with the night and
now suddenly again Black's playing
without most of his army yeah pretty
much uh the most important piece here
here for black to activate is that rook
and now it's never getting out white
could just land a bishop on G6 and black
is pretty much stalemated on the king
side for the rest of the game uh so this
would be a disaster for Wesley so
meaning that his two most natural moves
are not feasible right now look at
Wesley so staring up at the ceiling
looking for inspiration because suddenly
realizing F5 has a flaw in it that would
be a nasty check G6 also just too loose
too weakening so you have to allow the
white Pawn forward but that's far from
ideal that's suddenly a bit scary wesle
so maybe didn't see that one coming we
didn't hear in the studio that is a mark
of Genius for Magnus gson that's why
he's so strong in these queenless type
of positions he's still looking for
resources still looking for threats
putting a rook on the defile was just so
natural and for Magnus he was spending
that time there not because he was
thinking of which Rook to move he's
thrusting that pawn forward and he is
posing some direct problems I I thought
this wouldn't be a direct battle I
thought there would be no confrontation
here and Wesley you look at him peering
at the board he's like I need to buckle
down right now I'm I'm actually trailing
on the clock I spent 2 and a half
minutes on this turn and suddenly it's
Magnus once again with a lead on time
and with a better position I mean I just
want to take this moment to think about
the last two moves by Magnus Rook
sliding onto D1 Rook sliding onto E1 the
most natural looking moves in the
position moves that you make in seconds
first Magnus Retreats with that Bishop
making everyone think that eventually he
will slide in with the Rook go in with
the Knight and then he pushes this F2
Pawn to F4 again Magnus just doing
Magnus things in end game creating magic
out of out of nowhere out of a place
where you'd feel it never exists forcing
Wesley to take some big decisions right
now at least putting him under pressure
to solve these problems Wesley develops
with a check but in the bargain he gives
up a bishop pair and David I see your
expression you do not like Wesley's last
move I do have a bias towards the bishop
pair especially in an open position like
this but it feels like Wesley's just
giving Magnus a helping hand we were
talking about white having to take two
three moves to set up ideas of jumping
in with the white knight napping the
bishop pair Wesley's just given it for
free to Magnus Carson right now and yes
the black Rook is active yes the black
Rook actually covers the fifth rank
stopping White's porn from landing on F5
stopping any checks but what's left on
the board it's not about what's off the
board it's what's left and White's two
Bishops have great potential Black's
Knight doesn't have any stable squares
to sit on cannot really compete right
now with the Bishops longterm as well I
think this is just going to favor White
there might be no immediate knockout but
longterm now Wesley is going to be
suffering and Wesley down to nearly 3
minutes at this stage and maybe he can
try to improve his knight jump out to B6
he does just that but at any moment that
dark Square Bishop for white which has
no counterpart can slide forward to D4
take that Knight if it ever becomes a
problem and that F5 Pawn push that we
thought might occur it could happen at
any moment so for Wesley he's kind of
holding on to key squares but you could
see his pieces getting dislodged and
then Magnus will be able to press
forward yeah once again Bishop E2 F4 I
think these are these are exactly the
kind of moves that makes Magnus Carlson
the best player in the world well the
best player in the world in general but
the greatest of all times when it comes
to end games and we see that Bishop has
landed on D4 putting pressure on that
Rook Wesley immediately slides it to A5
so provoking Magnus to make some Pawn
decisions on the queen side A3 but that
Rook on A5 to me it looks misplaced you
have to be sure that you know you've
gone all the way there but you better be
able to find a way back yeah Black's
Rook could just be feeling silly uh on
that square especially if it later gets
kicked around even further by Whit's
pawns Whit's Bishops Wesley so a bit of
a shake of the head he looks away from
the board remember in one of the
previous games he was doing this all the
time and then he won so let's not trust
Wesley's body language too much but I
think internally he is a bit upset that
this position is spiraling slightly out
of control it's definitely Magnus trying
to make things happen dictating the uh
pace of this game and I don't know if
Magnus will even react to these Pawn
pushes white can start improving pieces
as well but Magnus is down to 2 minutes
30 seconds and the clock is ticking so
if he does not find the energetic
reply speaking of energetic replies he
gives up the A2 Pawn on the spot I think
he smells blood right now and if Wesley
takes this Pawn with his Rook that
Bishop is going to go all the way up to
the H5 square with check he's going to
push his Pawn to F5 he's just using his
pieces his pawns is battering rams he
doesn't care about that pawn on A2 and
look at Wesley right now exhaling
violently there he cannot take that pawn
if black takes that pawn with his Rook
he loses the game it is poisoned right
now he has to try and coordinate his
pieces yet again keep the black Rook on
the fifth rank the black Rook has too
many things to guard he has to
recentralize it but it's just come from
that side of the board it's so hard
psychologically to correct your own
mistake to lose a move for free
essentially he has to bring the black
Rook back to the center but he has to
lose the move he could be losing on the
spot if if he went Pawn hunting he puts
the Rook back on D5 and Wesley realizes
what a mistake he made on that last move
sliding The Rook to the edge of the
board now the bishop can step in with
Tempo to F3 further pursuing that black
rook and if white is able to get control
of the defile be the winner of that open
D line that would make Wesley's End Game
Play even more difficult Bishop H5 will
always be a threat you start with Bishop
F3 and ask bigger questions to The Rook
The Rook is going to be kicked about and
it's going to have to step back towards
the black camp and for Magnus sometimes
you push pawns and you regret it because
they become loose or overextended here
you're happy to get those pawns forward
whoa wesle Rook to B5 and the engine's
going through the roof that was another
blunder The Rook is just trapped on this
Square Magnus can close a cage around
this Rook I think the most natural move
in the position as well White's Dart
Square Bishop just slides into C5
cutting off the rook's access to the
fifth rank it's caught in a cage on its
own trapped by a bishop and pawn and
that Rook will fall off the board
Magnus could wrap up match Victory and
the Champions chest off final and he
finds it the black Rook on B5 is trapped
he had to fight against the threats of
A4 he steps in with the Knight to try
and grab that Bishop on C5 but now that
check on H5 that we were earlier
alluding to that's a square that isn't
defended anymore Bishop H5 F5 are these
ideas that are possible right now you
could go for that you could just drop
the bishop back to E2 and say give me
your Rook because he didn't sacrifice
The Rook he got his Rook trapped and
he's going to regret it so he's trying
to give up his Rook for the dark score
Bishop maybe get a pawn in return but I
think that for Wesley so here he is
hoping that some tactics will work out
his favor with a knight C3 jump things
of that nature I don't actually believe
that it should pan out and Magnus now
he's about to retreat the bishop and
he's so indecisive and then he finally
plays Bishop to2 now under a minute he
goes for material and Wesley jumping in
to pick up the other Bishop has to give
a check cuz the Knight would have taken
the bishop that was a skew on on C4 yeah
and now jumping out the way with a check
has meant that the white Bishop for now
is out of the eyeline of the Black
Knight White's Rook can save itself by
gaining time against Black's Knight
Wesley he's trying to hold things
together with tactics but they don't
work we see the evaluation B it's
through the roof Magnus Carlson will win
if he finds this move he hits the Black
Knight no good squares for this Knight
If It Moves white can save his Bishop
Magnus Carlson now should be winning the
bishop jump jumps in this is skew on the
white Rooks so many pieces are under
attack the bishop on H5 as well but I
think you can throw in a check bring
your Rook forward in the position but
many loose pieces he does deliver that
check and Wesley's King goes forward
rather than back you didn't want to have
your king in last rank there would have
been a skewer can't Magnus bring his
Rook back with another check and he's up
in exchange yeah the other white Rook
will save itself I think we might be
seeing the last few moves of the 2023
Champions chess tour Magnus Carson will
save his remaining Rook on F1 swing at
across Black's Knight Black's Bishop a
skewed any moment now we need to see
both players we might see a handshake
and we see Magnus he continues the
Knight and the Rook are lined up Magnus
under 20 seconds but it's going to be
enough Wesley is he about to give up
it's hopeless nothing to do look at the
black pieces one of them will drop off
and he's trying one or two final tricks
here Wesley so but look at this both
pieces forked that's it and that's it
Magnus Carlson does it we have a winner
it is him it was always going to be him
Magnus Carlson the Undisputed king of
speed chess wins the Champions Chester
finals and you hear Wesley say something
towards Magnus
94 he's asking him about the
theory
uhhuh yeah they were discussing their
opening it's all about the chest for
these guys but relief on Magnus
Carlson's face we saw it suddenly a
smile and he deserves every moment
handshake there from Judith our Arbiter
he is the champion but but uh Wesley so
he put up a great fight lots of credit
to Wesley but that's a $200,000 smile if
you're Magnus Carlson because you just
made Bank you take first place you get
all the congratulations in the world and
also a cool
200k Magnus cson wins his third title of
the Champions chestar and he can't hide
that smile it is time for him to
celebrate and what a run he had in the
round robin finishing second at the top
with Wesley taking down the world number
two in the semifinals after a big fight
and the finals it was a Magnus Carlson
show Magnus Carlson yesterday got that
one win that he needed the other games
were drawn today he won the first one
suffered defeat in game two so Wesley so
he came out slugging but in that fourth
and final game he played an opening that
Wesley did not know fully and W you
heard Wesley ask after the game what
should I have done there Magnus had the
answers Wesley did
not that game for Magnus starting slow
trades of the queens and then finally
does Magnus things in the end game
grinds it down and these are the final
moments of the Champions test St coming
in from
Toronto and we see Toronto celebrates
Magnus Carlson's win what a performance
and game four David he gets the job done
Magnus Carlson he got the job done he
grinded it out like a grandmas in the
end winning this queenless middle in
great style thanks to the power of the
two Bishops and I just want to show
where Wesley So eventually went wrong
it's a really difficult position for
black this Rook under heavy fire it's
been kicked around the board already for
a few moves but it found itself trapped
on a poor Square Wesley should have
retreated this Rook back to either D7 or
d8 back to safety any safe Square along
the D line but instead he brought it to
a square it was caught in a net Magnus
closed the cage here and suddenly it
must have dawned on Wesley that this
Rook is simply going to fall victim to
either the white Bishop or even the
white Pawn in certain variations he
tried his best to muddy the waters
weslio with a night jump but after a hit
on the black Rook it was forced to give
up its life and after this Knight Fork
the white Bishop was able to save itself
Bishop to H5 check a series of really
nice counterattacking moves by Magnus
Carlson a series of accurate moves first
jumping out the way forcing a block next
hitting the Black Knight if the Knight
moves the white Bishop saves itself
Magnus being up a rook for a knight
right now but this skewer allowed Magnus
to show off the real trick first a check
and then another check and finally the
other Rook which was asleep for so long
skewers these two pieces one final move
the Knight dropping back hitting White's
Rook allowed a simple drop back the
pieces are forked white emerges with a
decisive material advantage Wesley so
had to resign and that one move in the
opening really cost Wesley because that
rook in the corner it never moved for
black so for Wesley so he did not know
the opening we heard him ask Magnus
about it and for Magnus what a game that
was B4 sacrificing upon PA understanding
the black king wasn't fully safe either
precisely because that rook in the
corner couldn't get out so Magnus he
understood the Dynamics of the position
he was able to not just trap that Rook
but after that the ensuing complications
he had figured it all out gave a couple
checks skewer it some pieces won the
game on the spot and against the world
number one sometimes one move is enough
to lose uh to lose it all and that's
what Magnus just showed one inaccuracy
by Wesley creating those lights Square
weaknesses and that just gave Magnus
enough to outplay in that end game with
precision and he gets his hatrick title
in the Champions Chester only Magnus
Carlson can do what he hasn't done
before David this guy is Unstoppable
he's Unstoppable we hear from his fellow
players how much admiration they have
for him Magnus and it's just because he
has this Universal style he can play any
position any opponent adapt his game
he's been at the top of world chest now
for so long and that's not coincidence
he's so clever in every type of position
and yes he's got a bunch of Rivals yes
the new generation's coming up but
Magnus for now is still the king and
sometimes people get tired of the same
person winning over and over again
Magnus Carlson literally doesn't care
he's going to keep winning if he plays
his best chess until somebody dethrones
him he dethroned himself by not
continuing the world championship title
he didn't care about that he's won the
Champions chess to title three years in
a row congratulations are also in order
to Wesley so as well as the other
competitors they gave it the all but
Magnus Carlson once again ends up on top
the greatest of all time strikes again
and is the winner of the Champions chest
T and with that well it's time for us in
the Oslo Studio we've had a blast
calling the action but now it's time to
go into celebrations in Toronto Ka is
with the winner and everyone else take
it
away yeah thank you Tanya David Robert
and everyone in the Oslo Studio thank
you so much to all of you we love you it
is now time for the trophy ceremony here
in Toronto to my right two of the main
Men Behind the Champions chest St season
2023 it's Eric and Danny Danny you've
been here the whole week your passion
for chess has been so visible how will
you sum up this week oh wow summing of
this week has has been a a roller
coaster but it it feels like it was
meant to be like it's been a long time
coming to try to build on the amazing
Champions chess tour that started as I
guess the Magnus tour the the the the
then the the Champions chess tour and
then obviously everything that has been
happening in online chess over the last
few years has just been incredible but
it never felt like we had not just the
two best guys the eight best players
really getting everyone together to see
it all come down to this I feel like it
delivered and it just felt like a dream
come true yeah Eric you come here the
last couple of days you must be a proud
CEO right now I am I'm proud of our team
everybody here who's done this everyone
who's been involved in the Champions St
for so long and of course of the players
and all the competitors um I could not
be happier and I I want to clarify real
quick these are not for us these are for
the players Wesley if you'll still go on
a date with me those are for you right
there but I just wanted people to know
we were not holding those flowers for us
I felt awkward and wanted to give them
away I'm sorry yeah yeah feels more
natural with the flowers over here y
Eric I was going to ask you because I
know in chess come it's all about go
chess grow chess Y what is the future
now this is just this is just the
beginning for chess I mean obvious we've
seen a couple different waves of Chess
but the biggest waves are yet to come
and we are going to see you know the
game is going to grow the community is
going to grow and we're going to see
bigger and better events um and you know
thanks to all the players who are who
are putting themselves out there for the
fans and this is just the start yeah and
Danny what will you say about our two
finalists here this week what can you
say I mean you're looking at I think two
the two best rapid players on the planet
not taking anything away from the fact
that there were so many amazing chess
players here and I just lost my lost my
sound but I think that I think it's been
incredible I'm so appreciative to not
just the chess played but just who you
guys are and how you interact with the
fans and I think that like Eric said I
think the best is yet to come but it's
because we have players like this to
build around and I'm just uh I'm just
impressed and a fan and excited about
the future 100% and Wesley you are the
runner up you've given it an incredible
fight here so much entertainment
congratulations on second place in the
Champions Chester 2023 yeah thank you so
much I just want to congratulate Magnus
for a will the third performance so a
big a big Applause I will join in on
that yeah an Applause to you as well
Wesley what has this experience here in
Toronto been like uh yeah it's been
wonderful obviously I had a great result
last year also this year was really good
like couldn't ask for anything better uh
the people are really friendly and
really nice here and everyone's been so
nice like to thank the fans also the
sponsors and also the chess.com
Community all the staff has been very
very really good people you know my
Michael thank you I mean you yeah thank
you so much for everything also Danny
and Eric also all the staff here so
really wonderful thank you Wesley and uh
well as I said you gave it an incredible
fight you won one incredible game today
as well but Magnus here he takes it a
third time the Champions Chester what
will it take to knock this guy off the
throne you need to ask him yeah you need
to ask him yeah well I will ask Magnus
later on because right now you guys it
is time for the official Trophy
presentation I'm going to hand it over
to your commissioner Michel Brado thank
you ka this has been the most thrilling
week of Chess I could have possibly
imagined to all the fans watching from
home from their local chess club or from
our fans on here in Toronto thank you
for your enthusiasm and your
support Magnus you've done it time and
time again against the absolute best
players in the world and you defended
your title here at the 2023 Champions
test tour finals congratulations
all
right all
right that is a very cool trophy
congratulations Magnus what do you
think it looks good uh is there um a
digital version as well or is it uh
there is an nft version of this one as
well that is correct but I get to take
this one right you get to take the
physical one home magnus's uh third
consecutive Champions chest title just
incredible uh what has this season been
like what's been the highlight for you I
think the Highlight certainly has been
this tournament um it's been it's been
so much fun the the format I think has
worked out great um bringing excitement
till uh till the very end also yeah it's
good to be here in a good environment
with uh basically all the best um best
players and
um I I I mean personally I'm very very
happy happy with the way the event ended
uh the very last game cuz it sort of for
me it sort of comes full circle
cuz when we had the first Champions
chess Tour
event um in 2020 I think that was when I
turned 30 and I lost to Wesley in the
final that's exactly when sort of this
line uh in the Queen's Gambit that
Wesley played today was I mean I
wouldn't say it was invented it was a
little bit known but Wesley was kind of
the one who introduced it and made it
just very difficult to play D4 at all
like it's the Berlin of versus D4 so to
actually like win a game like decide the
Tour by winning a game against Wesley in
that line that's really comes full
circle for me oh that's fantastic cuz I
was thinking full circle would be one B3
the one the one goal you had left here
in the CCT 2023 so will that Happ prep
hard for it I thought I Magnus got to
play it today well does that mean we're
going to see that next season you have
another goal you need to take off next
season Magnus yeah or probably I should
think more before I write down
my good point well Magnus um this is the
third consecutive one I I promised
Wesley I would ask you what will it take
to knock you off the throne I think
several people have been close uh and I
did lose a couple of matches this uh
this season as well or more more than a
more than a couple so you know I am I'm
still pretty good so I still win some of
the time but I I don't win all the time
so um you know but um yeah I'm it's not
going to be um be easy anytime time soon
I don't think so yeah he's not going to
make it easy this guy he is your 20 23
Champions chess tour Champion to all the
players to all our fans a big thank
thank you for following us this season
there will be a next season of the
Champions chest tour so the excitement
continues in a few months you guys but
for now what an excitement we've had
here in Toronto it's been such a cool
week and we hope you guys have enjoyed
it enjoyed our top players giving it
their very best what a fun week it's
been we're going to celebrate Magnus
Carlson here now and the runner up
Wesley so so a big thank you to everyone
for following we'll see you again bye
from Toronto
B3 for the second day in a row Magnus
pauses gives a check comes back with the
Rope there's panic and Magnus picks up
another Pawn no time Wesley so he made
that move with 1 second left he gives up
Wesley so
resigns Wesley show wins the game what a
comeback Magnus Carson does it we have a
winner it is him it was always going to
be him Magnus Carlson the Undisputed
king of speed
[Music]
chess